COMPETING WITH A LOT OF
DIFFERENT THINGS GOING ON TODAY
IN THE BUILDING BUT WE ARE GOING
TO GET STARTED.
AS A SUB COMMITTEE IT'S AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING SO -- AND
SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND AND
START THIS WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS PERCENT TEAM BUT I A WILL
OPEN UP AND SOME.
REMARKS AND AFTER MYSELF IT'LL
BE MERRY SOMEWHERE YOU WANT TO
MAKE YOUR WAY OVER -- THAT WOULD
BE GRATEFUL.
THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
WHEN I WELCOME EVERYONE TO
TODAY'S HEARING IT'S AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
JOINT LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES?
AND THE FIRST ANNUAL EMISSIONS
UPDATE FROM THE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE BOARD AS
MANDATED.
BY ASSEMBLY BILL ONE NINETY
SEVEN TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I
THINK YOU MISS NICHOLS FOR
MAKING TIME FOR THIS UPDATE
TODAY.
WOULD LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE
ELSE IS GOING TO BE PRESENTING
TO IT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO THE
DISCUSSION.
ON I THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING ON THIS AS WELL.
TODAY'S HEARING WILL PROVIDE AN
INFORMATIONAL REPORT ON THE
REPORTED GREENHOUSE GASES
CRITERIA.
POLLUTANTS AND TOXIC
CONTAMINANTS FROM ALL SECTORS
COVERED BY AIR BE SCHOOL BE
IMPLIED.
AS REQUIRED BY AB.
ONE NINETY SEVEN THIS REPORT
SHOULD INCLUDE AN EVALUATION OF
THE MISSION TRANSCEND
INFORMATION REGARDING THE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
INITIATIVES AND OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT MAY INFLUENCE THOSE
STRENGTH -- WE'RE GONNA BE
LOOKING AT GHG EMISSIONS AND
I'VE ASKED THE PRESENTERS TO
ALSO HELP WITH LOOK AT ONE OF
OUR COMMUNITIES AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE AFFECTED WITH --
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT'S ALREADY
HERE ACTUALLY I DON'T WANT TO
SAY THAT THAT'S COMING BUT IS
ALREADY HERE ALONG THE WAY.
AND SO AT THE CONCLUSION WILL
ALLOW FOR PUBLIC COMMENT ON AND
YOU WILL JUST BE ABLE TO LINE UP
FOR THAT.
WITH KEEPING.
TODAY AND MINE IN THE SCHEDULE
AND THE MANY PLACES THAT ALL OF
THE MEMBERS AND PEOPLE PRESS ANY
TO BE AT I HOPE TO CHURN BY FOUR
PM -- BUT IF WE NEED TO BE HERE
LONGER I WILL BE HERE.
LONGER.
AND SO MERRY -- THE CHAIR MARY
NICHOLS IS HERE AND SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND I WILL GO AHEAD AND HAND
THIS OVER FOR YOU TO MAKE
COMMENTS AND ROB GIVE US YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT THE BEST
SLIDE UP THERE IS A BIT
DECEPTIVE BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
MUCH THAT FOLLOWS BEHIND IT
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF CHARTS --
IN THE HANDOUT THAT WE HAVE FOR
YOU TODAY BUT I'M NOT GOINGTO
BE DOING A SLIDE SHOW FOR YOU.
I AM MARY NICHOLS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND LIKE TO START OFF BY
CONGRATULATING THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON HER NEW POSITION.
AS WELL AS TO SAY THAT I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU IN
THIS NEW ROLE AND I'M
PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO BE
PARTICIPATING IN THIS FIRST
HEARING.
ON THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN TO DISCUSS THE
STATE'S PROGRESS ON AIR QUALITY
AND EMISSIONS TRENDS.
AND THE SCOPING PLAN.
LOOKING OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
THE LEGISLATION ADMINISTRATION
OF WORK TOGETHER TO PASS AND GET
SIGNED A SERIES OF BILLS THAT
ADDRESS EMISSIONS IN COMMUNITIES
SHORT LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
AND GREENHOUSE GASES.
AND THESE ARE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
THAT I THINK CALIFORNIA
COLLECTIVELY -- SHOULD BE
CELEBRATING.
OUR WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDS BACK TO WHEN CARP WAS
CREATED OVER FIFTY YEARS AGO
WITH THE GOALS OF ATTAINING AND
MAINTAINING HEALTHY AIR QUALITY.
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC FROM
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS PROVIDING
INNOVATIVE APPROACHES FOR
COMPLYING WITH AIR POLLUTION
RULES AND REGULATIONS AND LATER
WITH REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
SO LET'S LOOK AT HOW WE'VE DONE.
ON AIR QUALITY THE EPA SAYS
HEALTH BASED STANDARDS AND IS
REQUIRED BY FEDERAL LAW TO
REVIEW HOW THOSE STANDARDS ARE
COMPARING WITH THE LATEST
SCIENCE. TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
HEALTH PROTECTIVE.
OXIDES OF NITROGEN CALL KNOCKS
AT THE KEY SMOG FORMING
POLLUTANTS THAT WE WORK TO
CONTROL AND YOU HAVE A CHART IN
YOUR HAND OUT WHICH SHOWS
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRESS.
IN REDUCING SMOG FORMING KNOCKS
EMISSIONS AS EVIDENCED BY STATE
WIDE AIR MEASUREMENTS.
THE CURVE THAT DROPS TO THE LEFT
TO THE RIGHT SHOWS KNOCKS
EMISSIONS DECREASING NEARLY 70%
SINCE THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
BASED ON THE REGULATE SINCE THAT
HAVE BEEN ENACTED TO DATE.
THIS PROGRESS REFLECTS THE
BENEFITS OF BOTH CARB AND EPA
PROGRAMS FOR MOBILE SOURCES.
WHITE CARS TRUCKS AND OTHER
EQUIPMENT AS WELL AS AIR
DISTRICT PROGRAMS FOR STATIONARY
SOURCES -- BECAUSE THESE MOBILE
SOURCES ARE RESPONSIBLE 480% OF
KNOX EMISSIONS MORE STRINGENT
ENGINE STANDARDS CLEANER FUELS
AND INCENTIVES TO TURN OVER THE
FLEET.
HAVE BEEN RESPONSIBLE FOR A
LARGE PORTION OF THIS PROGRESS.
FOR EXAMPLE EMISSIONS FROM A NEW
CAR TODAY I'M 99% LESS THAN A
CAR FROM THE EARLY NINETEEN
SEVENTIES WHEN I FIRST STARTED
WORKING IN THIS FIELD.
SO A TINY FRACTION OF WHAT WAS
ONCE ROUTINELY COMMENT.
AS YOU KNOW THE STANDARD SAID
HEARING CALIFORNIA ARE COPIED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD.
THUS PEOPLE WELL BEYOND OUR
BORDERS BENEFITFROM
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP ON CLEAN
AIR.
CARD IN THE DISTRICTS OF ALSO
WORKED TO REDUCE RISK FROM
EXPOSURE TO AIR TOXICS FROM
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES LIKE
REFINERIES SMALLER SOURCES LIKE
GASOLINE STATIONS AND OTHER
MOBILE SOURCES INCLUDING DIESEL
TRUCKS.
CALIFORNIA'S AIR TOXICS PROGRAM
BEGAN IN NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
WITH THE ADOPTION OF THE TOXIC
AIR CONTAMINANT IDENTIFICATION
AND CONTROL ACT.
SINCE THEN THE STATE HAS
IDENTIFIED OVER TWO HUNDRED
SUBSTANCES THAT ARE HAZARDOUS TO
HUMAN HEALTH INCLUDING LEAD
BENZENE TALL THE QUEEN AND
ASBESTOS.
AND WE'VE ALSO ADOPTED NUMEROUS
REGULATIONS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS.
OF AN EXPOSURE TO THOSE
POLLUTANTS -- FROM ALL KINDS OF
RESOURCES INCLUDING PHASING OUT
PERSONAGENS FROM DRY CLEANERS
WHICH WILL BE COMPLETED IN.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE AND
SUBSTANTIALLY LIMITING THE
LEVELS OF BENZENE AND GASOLINE.
TODAY THE STATE'S EFFORTS
CONTINUE TO FOCUS ON REDUCING
EMISSIONS OF DIESEL PARTICULATES
WHICH ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 70% OF
THE TOTAL NON CANCER RISK
RELATED TO AIR.
YOU ALSO HAVE A CHART IN YOUR
HANDOUT THAT SHOWS PROGRESS IN
REDUCING DIESEL PARTICULATE
EMISSIONS.
DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER HAS
DECREASED APPROXIMATELY 80%
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY MOBILE
SOURCES LIKE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
ARE RESPONSIBLE 490% OF THE
TOXIC DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER.
SO PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON THESE
SOURCES ARE PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS THAT HAS OCCURRED.
AND OVER THE LAST TWENTY FIVE
YEARS STATEWIDE EMISSIONS
ASSOCIATED AND THE ASSOCIATED
HEALTH IMPACTS FROM AIR TOXIC
EXPOSURE HAVE BEEN REDUCED BY
ABOUT 75%.
THE EXAMPLE THAT I GAVE FOR KNOX
AND DIESEL PARTICULATE ARE
INDICATIVE OF THE EMISSIONS
REDUCTION TRENDS ACROSS THE
STATE FOR A VARIETY OF
POLLUTANTS WHICH ARE ALSO
INCLUDED IN THE HAND OUT.
IN GENERAL EMISSIONS HAVE BEEN
TRENDING DOWN FOR CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS AND GREENHOUSE
GASES.
BECAUSE OF LOCAL AND STATE
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS.
INCENTIVES AND INITIATIVES OVER
THE LAST FIFTY YEARS CALIFORNIA
HAS ADOPTED MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED CLEAN AIR REGULATIONS
AND PROGRAMS.
THESE REGULATIONS RANGE FROM
SETTING VEHICLE EMISSIONS
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS FOR
CLEANER FUELS TO DEVELOPING
CLEANER FORMULATIONS FOR
CONSUMER PRODUCTS.
AND AIR DISTRICTS ARE ALSO HAVE
ADOPTED REQUIREMENTS FOR
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES THAT HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THIS PROGRESS AS
WELL INCLUDING REQUIRING
CATALYTIC CONTROLS ON POWER
PLANTS.
LOW NON SPOILERS AT REFINERIES
AND CLEANER COMBUSTION FOR SPACE
HEATING.
THESE NUMBERS AND TRENDS OVERALL
ARE IMPRESSIVE THE AIR IS
CLEANER STATEWIDE THIRTY
THOUSAND PREMATURE DEATHS ARE
AVOIDED TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND ASTHMA CASES HAVE BEEN
AVOIDED SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY AND ALL THE
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS GROWN TO BE
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD.
BUT LET ME BE CLEAR THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK STILL AHEAD OF US
APPROXIMATELY ONE THIRD OF
CALIFORNIA IS THIRTY NINE AND A
HALF MILLION RESIDENTS.
STILL LIVING COMMUNITIES THAT
EXCEED THE FEDERAL HEALTH
TANDARDS EXPOSURE TO DIESEL
PARTICULATES IS TOO HIGH
ESPECIALLY IN COMMUNITIES NEAR
FREIGHT FACILITIES SUCH AS PORTS
RAILYARDS DISTRIBUTION CENTERS.
AND PEOPLE WHO ARE LOCATED CLOSE
TO FREEWAYS AN INDUSTRIAL
SOURCES.
EXPOSURE TO OZONE POLLUTION IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA HAS LED TO A
10% INCREASE IN DEATHS FROM
THESE SOURCES.
FROM.
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN
IN RESPONSE TO AB ONE NINETY
SEVEN'S DIRECTION TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY AND PUBLIC ACCESS
TO EMISSIONS AND INVENTORY DATA.
CARB DEVELOP THE POLLUTION
MAPPING TOOL THE POLLUTION
MAPPING TOOL WHICH IS A PUBLICLY
WHICH IS PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON
THE CARD WEBSITE.
ALLOWS USERS TO IDENTIFY AND
COMPARE THE GREENHOUSE GAS
CRITERIA POLLUTANT TOXIC AIR.
EMISSIONS OF FACILITIES THAT
REPORT INTO OUR MANDATORY
GREENHOUSE GAS REPORTING PROGRAM.
WITH THE TOOL ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC CAN ZOOM IN AND EXAMINE
EMISSIONS WITHIN A COMMUNITY.
THE EMISSIONS DATA CONTAINED IN
THIS POLLUTION MAPPING TOOL IS
EXPANDED AND RESPONSE TO AB ONE
NINETY SEVEN AND NOW CONTAINS AN
ESTIMATE OF ANNUAL GREENHOUSE
GAS.
CRITERIA AND TOXIC EMISSIONS FOR
EACH FACILITY.
THE GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
DATA COLLECTED ANNUALLY THROUGH
CARBS MANDATORY GREENHOUSE GAS
REPORTING PROGRAM.
THESE -- ADMISSIONS DATA ARE
THEN REPORTED BY THE LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS THIS IS USEFUL DATA
BUT IT DOES HAVE SOME WEAKNESSES.
FOR EXAMPLE DIFFERENT DISTRICTS
IN DIFFERENT PARTS OF THE STATE
USE DIFFERENT METHODOLOGIES AND
DATA COLLECTION FOR REPORTING
CRITERIA POLLUTANT AND AIR
TOXICS.
EVEN FROM THE SAME SOURCES.
ADDITIONALLY SOME FACILITIES MAY
REPORT CRITERIA POLLUTANTS EVERY
THREE YEARS BECAUSE OF AIR
DISTRICT REPORTING THRESHOLDS
AND AIR TOXIC EMISSIONS EVERY
FOUR YEARS BASED ON REQUIREMENTS
FROM THE STATE'S AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT HOT SPOTS PROGRAM.
SO WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
DISTRICTS TO HARMONIZE REPORTING
METHODS AS WELL AS THE REPORTING
RECORD FREQUENCY AS PART OF THE
A. B. IX SEVENTEEN PROCESS.
AND I'LL TALK ABOUT THAT A
LITTLE BIT LATER STILL THE
POLLUTION MAPPING TOOL CAN HELP
COMMUNITIES TRACK EMISSION
TRENDS FROM FACILITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND COMPARE
THEM WITH EACH OTHER.
THE FIRST YEAR THAT WE STARTED
COLLECTING GREENHOUSE DATA WAS
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT SINCE THEN
SOME FACILITIES HAVE SEEN
EMISSIONS INCREASES AS
CALIFORNIA GREW OUT OF THE
RECESSION WHILE OTHERS HAVE SEEN
REDUCTIONS.
AND WE'RE LOOKING IN THE STATE
THAT YOU CAN SEE EMISSIONS VARY
FROM YEAR TO YEAR FOR INDIVIDUAL
FACILITIES WHICH IS NOT
SURPRISING BECAUSE THERE ARE
MANY REASONS ECONOMIC TECHNICAL
AND REGULATORY THAT INFLUENCE
AND FACILITIES EMISSIONS IN A
PARTICULAR YEAR.
THAT YOU CAN NOTE THAT EMISSIONS
FROM THE STATION FACILITIES ARE
SUBJECT TO ENFORCEABLE LIMITS BY
LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS.
RECENTLY THE STATE OF UP HAD THE
STATE HAS UPDATED THESE TRENDS
FIRM 200-082-2000 SEVENTEEN AND
THEY'RE ALSO WORKING ON WAYS TO
DISPLAY EMISSIONS FROM VEHICLES
IN ADDITION TO THE MAJOR
FACILITIES BY EARLY NEXT YEAR.
WE HAVE FOUND THAT ONE OF THE
USES OF THIS TOOL IS TO HELP
INFORM COMMUNITY EFFORTS LIKE
THOSE UNDER AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AND TO HELP THE
PUBLIC BETTER UNDERSTAND
EMISSIONS FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES
THAT MAY BE IMPACTING A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY AND TO
PRIORITIZE WHERE MORE ACTION IS
NEEDED.
WE EXPECT THIS TOOL WILL
CONTINUE TO BE A VALUABLE
RESOURCE AS WE ADD MORE SOURCES
IN THE FUTURE.
ENHANCE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
UNDER A. B. SIXTEEN AS WELL AS
THE DEVELOPMENT OF COMMUNITY
ACTION PLANS WILL ALSO HELP
PROVIDE GREATER TRANSPARENCY
REGARDING EMISSIONS AS WELL AS
TO TO DRIVE DOWN EMISSIONS IN
THOSE AREAS THAT ARE MOST IMPACT.
IMPACTED.
NOW AS I MENTIONED OUR EXISTING
WORK AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IS GOING
TO BE EXPANDING IN NEW WAYS
BECAUSE AB.
SIX SEVENTEEN AB SIX SEVENTEEN
IS THE MOST SIGNIFICANT
LEGISLATION ADDRESSING CRITERIA
POLLUTANT AND TALKS AND TOXIC
EMISSIONS SINCE THE ORIGINAL AB
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WAS
PASSED IN THE LATE NINETEEN
EIGHTIES.
THIS LEGISLATION FOCUSES ON
ADDRESSING AIR QUALITY ISSUES IN
OUR MOST IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
AB SIX SEVENTEEN REQUIRES CARP
TO DEVELOP A STATE STRATEGY THAT
OUTLINES MEASURES TO FURTHER
REDUCE CRITERIA POLLUTANT AN AIR
TOXIC EMISSIONS IN DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. TO DEVELOP
COMMUNITY MONITORING GUIDANCE
AND REQUIRE ENHANCED EMISSIONS
REPORTING FROM STATIONARY
SOURCES.
THE BILL RECOGNIZE THAT WHILE
THE STATE HAS SEEN TREMENDOUS
IMPROVEMENT IN AIR QUALITY THERE
ARE COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THOSE
THAT MAY MENTION THAT ARE NEAR
FREIGHT FACILITIES.
AS WELL AS THOSE THAT ARE NEAR
FREEWAYS THAT REMAIN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
POOR AIR QUALITY.
AND THESE COMMUNITIES REQUIRES
SPECIAL ATTENTION AND ACTION.
AS CAR MOVES FORWARD WITH AB SIX
SEVENTEEN IMPROVING THE
EMISSIONS INVENTORY WILL BE A
KEY COMPONENT OF ALL OF OUR
OTHER ACTIVITIES.
WITH INCREASING FOCUS ON DATA
QUALITY TIMELINESS ACCESSIBILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY.
SO AB ONE NINETY SEVEN AND AB
SIX SEVENTEEN WORK HAND IN HAND
TO SUPPORT FOCUSED EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS IN OUR MOST IMPACTED
COMMUNITIES OVER THE COMING
YEARS.
THIS IS WHY THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT NEW FRAMEWORK FROM
WHICH ALONG WITH EXISTING LAW
CAN LOOK AT THE DISPARITIES
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
IMPACTED THESE COMMUNITIES.
NOW.
THAT WE'VE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT TRANS AND REPORTING IS I'D
ALSO LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
CLIMATE CHANGE PROGRAM AND
ESPECIALLY ABOUT THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CLIMATE CHANGE SCOPING
PLAN.
THE PLAN WAS.
TO WITH A PUBLIC PROCESS AND
LEGISLATIVE INPUT OVER TWO AND A
HALF YEARS THE PLAN WAS
UNANIMOUSLY ADOPTED BY THE BOARD.
AND THE STAKEHOLDER SUPPORT FOR
ITS APPROVAL WAS OVERWHELMING.
WE ARE NOW WORKING ON THE
STATE'S THIRD SCOPING PLAN AND
WE'VE MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS SINCE ADOPTION OF THE
FIRST PLAN BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT AGAIN YOUR
HAND OUTS FOR TODAY SHOW HOW THE
ECONOMY AND POPULATION.
CONTINUED TO GROW LAW GHG
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CONTINUE TO DECLINE KEEPING US
ON TRACK TO MEET THE TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET.
IMPORTANTLY WE'RE ON TRACK TO
MEET OUR A. THIRTY TWO TARGET OF
NINETY REACHING NINETEEN NINETY
LEVELS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY I TWENTY SIXTEEN
LEVELS FELL BELOW THE TWENTY
TWENTY TARGET FOUR YEARS EARLIER
THAN MANDATED BY STATUTE.
AND OF COURSE THAT'S A GOOD
THING THAT SETS US UP WELL FOR
THE NEXT DECADE WE WILL NEED
EVEN STEEPER REDUCTION.
BUT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT MANY HAD ASSUMED THAT
REDUCED ECONOMIC ACTIVITY MUST
ACCOMPANY REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS.
BUT OUR EXPERIENCE OVER THE PAST
FEW YEARS HAS PROVED THAT TO BE
FALSE.
CALIFORNIA IS DEMONSTRATING TO
THE WORLD THAT YOU CAN DE COUPLE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
ECONOMIC GROWTH WHICH REALLY
MEANS YOU CAN GROW USING LESS
ENERGY TO DO IT AB LESS
POLLUTION.
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN SCOPING
PLAN CONTINUES THIS APPROACH
USING A MIX OF REGULATIONS
INCENTIVES AS WELL AS THE MARKET
BASED MECHANISM.
THAT PUTS A CAP ON EMISSIONS AND
ALLOWS FOR ALLOWANCE TRADING TO
ACHIEVE OUR TWENTY THIRTY TARGET.
USING A COMPREHENSIVE MIX OF
STRATEGIES AS DESCRIBED IN THE
SCOPING PLAN.
BUILD ON OUR SUCCESS OVER THE
LAST DECADE.
IN ADDITION TO REDUCING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS SEVERAL
STRATEGY THE SCOPING PLAN WERE
DEVELOPED AS PART OF THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO MEET FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS IN OUR STATE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN.
AND TO REDUCE TOXICS EMISSIONS
IN THE SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT
STRATEGY SO WE'RE REALLY TALKING
ABOUT TRIPLE THREAT.
STRATEGY INCLUDES PROGRAMS SUCH
AS THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD
AND RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
THAT ARE DELIVERING CLEANER
FUELS AND ENERGY.
THE ADVANCE CLEAN CARS PROGRAM
WHICH IS PUT MORE THAN A QUARTER
MILLION CLEAN VEHICLES ON THE
ROAD.
AND THE SUSTAINABLE FREIGHT
ACTION PLAN WHICH WILL RESULT IN
EFFICIENT AND CLEANER SYSTEMS TO
MOVE GOODS THROUGHOUT THE STATES.
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT A CAP AND
TRADE PROGRAM AS A PART OF THE
PACKAGE WITH OTHER MEASURES.
IS ESSENTIAL BECAUSE IT ALLOWS
US TO MEET OUR GOALS WHILE
SIMULTANEOUSLY ACHIEVING THE CO
BENEFIT OF IMPROVE PUBLIC HEALTH
AS A RESULT OF DIRECT INVESTMENT
OF DOLLARS.
IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
UNDERSCORES CALIFORNIA'S
CONTINUED NATIONAL AND
INTERNATIONAL LEADERSHIP ON
CLIMATE.
AGAIN ON THE ISSUE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WE
NEED TO NOTE THAT OF THE THREE
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS.
ASKED SPENT AS OF DECEMBER
201857% HAS BEEN SPENT IN WAYS
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO DIRECTLY
BENEFIT.
DISADVANTAGED AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES SO SLIGHTLY MORE
THAN HALF.
SINCE THE ADOPTION OF THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SCOPING PLAN WE'VE
MODIFIED AN ADOPTED SEVERAL OF
OUR PLANS AND REGULATIONS. TO
ASSURE THE EARLY AND LONG TERM
CERTAINTY FOR BUSINESSES TO PLAN
AND INVESTED IN EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS AFFECTS.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN CAR VOTED TO
SET GREENHOUSE GAS PLANNING
TARGETS FOR THE ELECTRICITY
SECTOR AND UTILITIES AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES.
WE VOTED TO STRENGTHEN AND
EXPAND OUR REGULATIONS FOR
VEHICLES CLEAN FEELS AS WELL AS
THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM.
AND HER SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS SUCH AS METHANE WE'VE
ADOPTED NEW REQUIREMENTS FOR
HIGH GLOBAL WARMING GASES THAT
ARE USED IN REFRIGERATION AND
FOAM.
SO WITH ALL OF THESE PLANS AND
REGULATIONS WE NEED TO MONITOR
AND TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU THE
LEGISLATURE AND WITH OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. TO SEE HOW IS
ACTUALLY WORKING IN ADDITION TO
THE DATA THAT WE COLLECT TO
COLLECT REAL WORLD INFORMATION
ABOUT.
NOT ONLY HOW WE'RE DOING BUT HOW
WE COULD BE DOING BETTER NOW WE
COULD MAKE CORRECTIONS MIDWAY AS
NEEDED. ONE MAJOR DEVELOPMENT
THAT WILL SUPPORT AYE MANDATES
UNDER AB EIGHT ONE NINETY SEVEN
IS THE DEVELOP A DEVELOPMENT OF
NEW STATEWIDE STATIONARY SOURCE.
EMISSIONS A NEW EMISSIONS
REPORTING REGULATIONS THEY'VE
WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS INDUSTRY GROUPS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH GROUPS OVER
THE PAST YEAR. TO DEVELOP THIS
REGULATION WHICH IS NOW IN THE
PROCESS OF BEING FINALIZED.
IN DECEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEENTH
THE CARDBOARD ALSO APPROVED THE
REGULATION FOR REPORTING OF
CRITERIA AND TOXIC AIR
CONTAMINANTS.
THIS REGULATION REQUIRES ANNUAL
REPORTING TO KERR.
OF CRITERIA POLLUTANT AND TOXIC
CONTAMINANT ADMISSIONS.
FROM SPECIFIED FACILITIES AND I
REALIZE THIS MAY SOUND LIKE IT'S
OBVIOUS BUT YOU HAVE TO REALIZE
THAT THERE IS NO PLACE ELSE THAT
WE ARE AWARE OF WHERE YOU CAN
TAKE A PARTICULAR FACILITY.
AND FIND IN ONE PLACE THE DATA
ABOUT THESE DIFFERENT TYPES OF
EMISSIONS THEY HAVE BEEN THREE
SEPARATE PROGRAMS FOR MANY MANY
YEARS BUT WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
REALLY COLLECTING.
THE DATA AND LOOKING AT IT IN A
MORE COHERENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
WAY WHICH WE THINK WILL ALSO
HELP US.
DEVELOP BETTER AT SOLUTIONS TO
HOW TO BRING EMISSIONS DOWN EVEN
FURTHER.
SO -- THIS REGULATION --
OBVIOUSLY WAS DESIGNED -- TO
ADDRESS THE LEGISLATIVE
REQUIREMENT BUT AGAIN IT ALSO
SUPPORTS THE CARBS NEEDS FOR A
BETTER INVENTORY TO USE FOR
OTHER PURPOSES AS WELL AND MANY
OTHER PROGRAMS COULD BENEFIT
FROM MORE.
COMPREHENSIVE AND UPDATED
EMISSIONS INVENTORIES AS WELL.
THESE PROGRAMS INCLUDING OUR AIR
TOXIC CONTROL MEASURES IN THE
STATE IMPLEMENTATION PLAN LAYOUT
PROCESS SEES TO ADDRESS
MITIGATION IN AREAS THAT EXCEED
THE FEDERAL STATE FEDERAL AND
STATE AIR QUALITY STANDARDS.
AND THE PUBLIC RIGHT TO KNOW
TENANTS OF AB ONE NINETY SEVEN
INCLUDING A REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE EMISSIONS INVENTORY ON
STATIONARY SOURCES AT THE LOCAL
AND SUB COUNTY LEVEL ON OUR
WEBSITE.
SO THE REGULATION IS GOING TO
REQUIRE -- MAJOR ACT ACTIVITY
MAJOR EFFORT BUT IT IS WORTH IT
IN TERMS OF WHAT IT WILL ALLOW
US TO DO -- GOING FORWARD.
SO -- I'D LIKE TO SAY THAT
REALLY THE BIGGEST STRATEGIES --
IN THE TRY TO WIND UP HERE
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU WANT TO HEAR
FROM OTHER PEOPLE AND PRESUMABLY
ALL HAVE QUESTIONS AS WELL.
BUT TO LOOK AT THE OVERALL
ISSUES OF AIR QUALITY AND
CLIMATE THERE IMPACTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND IN THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
THE SECTOR THAT STANDS OUT AS
OUR BIGGEST SOURCE OF EMISSIONS
OVERWHELMING ALL OTHERS IS
TRANSPORTATION.
IT ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT HALF OF
ALL OF THE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND 90% OF THE HOT
TOXIC DIESEL PARTICULATE
EMISSIONS.
AND THE LARGEST EMISSIONS
SOURCES INCLUDING TRUCKS TRAINS
AND SHIPS ARE ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
BE CONTROLLED IF WE'RE GOING TO
MEET OUR REDUCTION GOALS.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IN OUR OVERALL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM.
OUR APPROACH TO REDUCING
EMISSIONS IN THIS SECTOR
INCLUDES NEW TECHNOLOGIES FUELS
AS WELL AS SPENDING.
DOLLARS -- TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES --
FOR THE INTRODUCTION OF CLEANER --
TECHNOLOGIES AND ALSO INCLUDES
SUSTAINABLE IMPROVEMENTS IS IN
SUSTAINABLE LAND USE PLANNING
BUT A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF OUR
SUCCESS IN THE SECTOR DEPENDS ON
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
I THINK AS YOU ALL KNOW THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION IN
WASHINGTON DC IS IN THE BUSINESS
OF DISMANTLING THE FEDERAL
RESPONSES TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND
CLEAN AIR.
BETWEEN DISBANDING THE FEDERAL
CLIMATE ADVISORY PANEL.
RESCINDING THE CLEAN POWER PLAN
COURT ACTIONS TO ROLL BACK
FEDERAL LAWS AND POTENT SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANTS
REDUCTION STRATEGIES AS WELL AS
WITHDRAWING FROM.
OUR INTERNATIONAL CLIMATE
AGREEMENT.
EVERY MONTH BRINGS ANOTHER
ALARMING ROLL BACK OF FEDERAL
POLICIES THAT HAVE.
PROVIDED THE UNDER GIRDING FOR
OUR PUBLIC HEALTH ACTIVITIES AT
THE STATE LEVEL FOR ALL THESE
YEARS.
CALIFORNIA THEREFORE IS LOOKED
TO BY OTHERS AS WELL AS
OURSELVES -- TO CONTINUE TO LEAD
THE WAY NOT ONLY AS A LIVING
EXAMPLE OF HOW TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS WHILE CONTINUING TO
GROW A THRIVING ECONOMY BUT ALSO
TO PROVIDE THE IMPETUS FOR NEW
TECHNOLOGY INNOVATION.
THE STATE HAS TO LOOK FORWARD I
HAD OF ANY PARTICULAR ELECTION
CYCLE AND ANY PARTICULAR
ADMINISTRATION IN WASHINGTON AND
THE HERE AS A STEADY SOURCE.
OF GUIDANCE INTO THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER WE ARE -- CLEARLY
RECOGNIZING THE DANGER FROM
WHAT'S GOING ON IN WASHINGTON.
AND IT'S A THREAT NOW DIRECTLY
TO ATTACK THE STATE'S ABILITY TO
ADOPT MORE STRINGENT.
STANDARDS PARTICULARLY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE WAIVERS THAT WE'VE
ENJOYED FOR STRICTER CAR
STANDARDS UNDER THE CLEAN AIR
ACT.
IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN OUR WAIVERS --
OVER THE YEARS WE HAVE LITIGATED
WE HAVE ADVOCATED WE HAVE HAD
GOVERNOR'S VISIT WASHINGTON
EVERY TIME THERE WAS A THREAT --
BUT THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE
HAVE BEEN.
IN A SITUATION WHERE WE'VE BEEN
TOLD THAT A WAIVER WHICH HAS
ALREADY BEEN GRANTED FOR
ADOPTING THAT PAVLEY STANDARDS
THAT DEAL WITH GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
WAS GOING TO BE -- ACTUALLY WITH
TO DRAW ON AND SO WE'RE WORKING
VERY HARD AND HAPPY TO SAY THAT
WE'VE BEEN JOINED NOW BY TWENTY
THREE OTHER STATES AND HAWAII
AND I'M AND TO PUT A RICO -- AS
A ADVOCATES -- FOR FOR US
BLOCKING THIS ACTION AT NOT TO
MENTION MANY -- BUSINESS
ORGANIZATIONS AND NGOS AS WELL.
WHILE WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A WAY
TO WORK PRODUCTIVELY WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHEN IT COMES
TO CALIFORNIA'S VEHICLE EMISSION
STANDARDS WE ARE BEING ATTACKED
AT THE VERY HEART OF OUR PROGRAM.
IF WE WERE TO LOSE THE ABILITY
TO SET EMISSION STANDARDS WE
WOULD CERTAINLY FIGHT VIGOROUSLY
AND AT THE END WE WOULD FIND A
WAY IS -- TO CONTINUE TO ACHIEVE
REDUCTIONS BUT THERE'S NOTHING
THAT IS AS EFFICIENT AND COST
EFFECTIVE AS OUR AS WE HAVE
FOUND -- IN IN ADVANCING
TECHNOLOGY FOR CONTROLLING MOTOR
VEHICLE EMISSIONS SO -- OUR
ABILITY TO REDUCE THESE
EMISSIONS -- IS REALLY IN THE
BALANCE AND COULD BE IMPAIRED --
pWOULD LIKE -- TO VITE YOUR
QUESTIONS AND TALK ABOUT HOW WE
CAN CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER --
TO BUILD ON THE COULD WORK
THAT'S BEEN DONE OVER MANY YEARS
AND AND TO MOVE ON TO A EVEN
BETTER DAYS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND SO I DO
YOU WANT TO ADD A KNOWLEDGE THAT --
WHEN AB?
ONE MAYBE SEVEN WAS PASSED WE
WERE PLAYING MORE OFFENSE UNLESS
DEFENSE I AND SO I AM AWARE NOT
JUST IN THIS BUT JUST IN GENERAL
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
A LOT OF OUR ENERGIES.
ARE GOING TOWARDS A DEFENSE
RIGHT NOW WHETHER IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA EMISSION STANDARDS OR
A NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS THAT WE
HAVE BEEN UNDER ATTACK ON THE
ENVIRONMENT A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS AND SO I KNOW THAT.
OUR ENERGIES ARE PRETTY TAX AND
AND PRETTY SPLIT RIGHT NOW.
WITH THAT BUT I DID WANT TO
TOUCH A LITTLE BIT MORE -- WE
ARE ON A PATHWAY. TO MEET OUR
TWENTY TWENTY G. H. T. ROLES --
THAT.
HELP MOTIVATE.
THE EXPANSION OF AB -- THIRTY
TWO AND TOWARDS YOUR GOALS. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY THIRTY AND SO
WANTED.
TO I GUESS HEAR YOUR OPINION
I'VE READ A COUPLE OF THINGS
ALONG THE WAY ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT WE'RE ON ON TRACK TO TO MEET
THOSE GOALS FOR WANTED TO HEAR
FROM YOU DIRECTLY OF WAITING FOR
AT MOVING TOWARDS OUR TWENTY
THIRTY GOALS.
SO WE DID HIT THE TWENTY TWENTY
GOAL IN TWENTY SIXTEEN BUT OF
COURSE -- ONE YEAR ADD DATA
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HOLD INTO
THE FUTURE -- WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THE ECONOMIC TRENDS AS I
MENTIONED BUT ALSO WEATHER
CONDITIONS AND OTHER THINGS THAT
MIGHT AFFECT OUR ABILITY TO
MAINTAIN THE PROGRESS THAT WE
STARTED -- I THINK IN TERMS OF
MOVING TOWARDS TWENTY THIRTY WE
BELIEVE THAT WE'RE IN PRETTY
GOOD SHAPE WITH A MIX OF TOOLS.
THAT WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO US
TODAY -- WE'RE DOING WELL ON A
RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES WERE SEEING --
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TAKING
INITIATIVES ON THE LAND USE FROM
TO TRY -- TO USE THEIR RESOURCES
MORE EFFICIENTLY AND TO HELP
WITH -- USING -- SOME OF THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE --
THROUGH THE GREENHOUSE GAS
PRODUCTION FUND TO BUILD MORE
LIVABLE COMMUNITIES EXPAND
TRANSIT AND WALKING AND BIKING
OPPORTUNITIES -- WE ARE TAKING A
WHOLE NEW LOOK AT INDUSTRIAL
FACILITIES AND WHAT CAN BE DONE --
LOOKING AT BUILDINGS WHERE WE
HAVE DONE A LOT IN CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE THEM EFFICIENT BUT WE STILL --
BURN A LOT OF NATURAL GAS AND
HEATING WATER AND HEATING
BUILDINGS AND THAT IS A BIG
SOURCE OF INDOOR AIR POLLUTION
AS WELL AS OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS -- WE'RE LOOKING AT TO
AGRICULTURE WHICH HAS -- HAS
BEEN OVER THE YEARS A MAJOR
SOURCE OF SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS TO SEE WHERE WE CAN --
FIND WAYS TO MAKE SOME BIG GAINS
THERE IN TERMS OF EFFICIENCY AND
ALSO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY AT THE
SAME TIME SO CAR IS BEEN GOING
SORT OF SECTOR BY SECTOR --
LOOKING AROUND TO SEE WHERE WE
CAN TIGHTEN THINGS UP AND WHERE
WE CAN DO BETTER -- BUT OVERALL
I THINK THROUGH TWENTY THIRTY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE TOOLS THAT WE
NEED ARE AVAILABLE IT'S WHEN WE
LOOK TOWARDS TWENTY FIFTY M. OUR
GOAL OF BECOMING -- CARBON
NEUTRAL OR AND THAT IS NOT
ADMITTING ANYTHING THAT WE SEE
THE AREAS WHERE WE FRANKLY DON'T
KNOW YET HOW WE'RE GOING TO GET
THERE.
WE KNOW WE'VE GOT TO DO A LOT
MORE TO MAKE OUR FORESTS -- AND
OUR LAND -- STORE MORE CARBON
EFFECTIVELY AND BECOME A NET
SINK INSTEAD OF A SOURCE OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
WE NEED TO FIND WAYS TO CAPTURE
CARBON LITERALLY IN THE AIR AND
TO FIND WAYS.
TO RE USE IT FOR BENEFICIAL
PURPOSES OR PERMANENTLY --
NEUTRALIZE IT THERE ARE
TECHNOLOGIES OUT THERE THAT ARE
BEING DEVELOPED THAT ARE BEING
WORKED ON BUT WE DON'T YET HAVE
THE PLANS IN PLACE AND THE TOOLS.
TO MAKE ALL OF THOSE THINGS
HAPPEN AND WE WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO LOOK FOR WAYS TO AB
ADVANCE THE SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY AND IN A NUMBER OF
THESE AREAS.
SO THEN WHEN -- THERE IS THERE'S
A A QUOTE WERE YOU PREVIOUSLY
SAID THAT.
THE STRATEGIES WE USE UNTIL NOW
HAVEN'T BEEN EFFECTIVE THAN THIS
WOULD FALL INTO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT WE WERE TRANSFERRED
OUT WITH THOSE TOOLS WOULD BE
MOVING FORWARD -- SO THAT WOULD
BE A FIRM TO PETITION.
YES I MEAN I THINK THAT THINGS
LIKE THE CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM
FOR EXAMPLE.
KIND OF SETTLED IN AS PART OF
EXPECTATIONS THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
AND THAT THE REGULATED INDUSTRY
HAS THAT THOSE WILL CONTINUE TO
EXIST AND THAT WILL CONTINUE --
TO RATCHET DOWN ON THE ON THE AD
LIMITS THAT US FACILITIES CAN
CAN HAVE -- AND THAT PEOPLE ARE
FINDING WAYS NOW INTERNALLY
WITHIN THEIR FACILITIES TO
REDUCE THEIR EMISSIONS AND THIS
IS REALLY WHAT THE WHAT THE
PROGRAM IS INTENDED. TO
ACCOMPLISH.
SO WE KNOW THAT.
BOTH DATA AND ON MY ANECDOTAL
EXPERIENCE GOING HOME EVERY
WEEKEND.
THAT WE HAVE -- INCREASED
EMISSIONS FROM.
OMAR TRANSPORTATION SECTOR
WHETHER IT'S THE TRUCKS ARE THE
FREIGHT AND I HAVE THE LUXURY OF
HAVING THE FREEWAYS THE
RAILYARDS THE POOR -- AND THEN
THE STATIONARY SOURCES ALSO AND
AND MIKE BACKYARD SO HEAVILY
IMPACTED COMMUNITY THERE AND WE
WE FEEL IT WITH THE ADDITIONAL
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD.
THERE HAVE BEEN EFFICIENCIES AT
THE PORT OF LONG BEACH THAT ARE
ADDING MORE TRUCKS ALSO AND SO
WHILE THE PORT ITSELF MIGHT BE A
LITTLE BIT GREENER THE TRUCKS
THAT ARE.
ON THE FREEWAYS ARE NOT GREEN
ARROW AND WE'RE ADDING MANY MORE
TRAXXAS HAS GOOD MOVEMENTS HAS
INCREASED AND IT'S TIED TO OUR
MARKET. TO EAT WE CONTINUE TO
SEE AN INCREASE ON
TRANSPORTATION -- AND FOR
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES OUT THERE.
WHAT ARE ORDER THOSE TRENDS MEAN
TO YOU AS FAR AS G. C. TARGETS
IN AND LOCAL COMMUNITIES YOU
KNOW IT THAT'S BEEN ONE OF MY
BIG PUSH OF GOING FROM REGIONAL
TO TO LOCAL?
I. SELFISHLY BECAUSE I LIVE
THEIR LIVES SURE I MEAN IT
EVERYBODY EXPERIENCES THESE
THINGS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHETHER YOU'RE IN AN AFFLUENT OR
A DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY BUT IN
PARTICULAR IF YOU'RE IN A
COMMANDING THE THIS IMPACTED BY
GOODS MOVEMENT -- YOU KNOW EVEN
IF YOU ARE TWIN OF THAT
ABSOLUTELY MOST IMPACTED YOU'RE
STILL GOING TO BE EXPERIENCING
WAVES OF TRAFFIC AND AND YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S VISIBLE AND
TANGIBLE AND IT HAS HEALTH.
IMPACTS AS WELL SO -- HAVING HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT YOUR
DISTRICT I KNOW YOU'VE GOT
SCHOOLS AND HOMES THAT ARE YOU
KNOW VERY CLOSE TO WHERE THESE
FACILITIES ARE.
AND WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO MOVE
FASTER I THINK A AND CUT DEEPER
FRANKLY I MEAN THAT WHAT WE'VE
DONE TO DATE.
IS NOT ENOUGH -- THIS YEAR AS
YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
GETTING AN INSPECTION PROGRAM
FOR TRUCKS BECAUSE OF WE CAN
ADOPT A REGULATION THAT'S WELL
AND GOOD.
BUT THE RATE OF NON COMPLIANCE
WITH THE REGULATIONS IN THAT
SECTOR IN PARTICULAR IS VERY
HIGH -- THERE WERE CERTAIN
NUMBER OF OF FLEETS ESPECIALLY
SOME OF THE LARGER FLEETS WHERE --
YOU KNOW THEY CAN AFFORD TO PUT
NEW EQUIPMENT ON AND BUY NEW
EQUIPMENT -- AND THEY DO THAT
PRETTY RAPIDLY OTHERS THAT ARE
SMALLER -- ARE REALLY OFTENTIMES
DELAYING OR AVOIDING -- ANY KIND
OF COMPLIANCE AND SO THIS YEAR
IS GONNA BE A BIG YEAR.
FOR THE FIRST TIME THERE WILL BE
OWNERS OF TRUCKS THAT WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO REGISTER THEM IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T MET.
THE CURRENT -- REQUIREMENTS FOR
UPGRADING THEIR FACILITIES AND
SO WE KNOW WE'VE BEEN OUT THERE
TRYING TO EDUCATE AND ADVOCATE
AND MAKE PEOPLE AWARE OF LOAN
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST AND SO FORTH
BUT IT'S STILL -- HI I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE AT A
SIGNIFICANT OUTCRY.
IN SOME QUARTERS WHEN PEOPLE
FIND THAT -- THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE
NOT IN COMPLIANCE AND THEY WON'T
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE. TO OPERATE
OUT OF COMPLIANCE AS THAT THAT
THE BOOM WILL GET WILL GET
LOWERED BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S IMPORTANT FACTOR OF
COURSE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IF
PEOPLE ARE COMPLYING THEY DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THEIR OPERATIONS
UNDER CUT BY SOMEBODY WHO CAN
GET AWAY WITH YOU KNOW.
NOT PAYING THE PRICE FOR PUTTING
ON UPDATED ADEQUATE MEANT BUT
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FUTURE AND
THE CONTINUED -- OPERATION OF
OUR LOGISTICS COMMUNITIES OF OUR
PORTS AND THE THE THROUGH PUT
THAT WE HAVE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE TOWARDS ZERO EMISSION
FREIGHT WHICH REALLY MEANS.
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE WHOLE
FREIGHT QUARTERS AND WHEN WE
START SPENDING MONEY TO UPGRADE
THOSE FACILITIES ARE WHEN WE SEE
PRIVATE INVESTMENTS IN THOSE
AREAS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE
LOOKING TOWARDS.
MUCH MUCH MORE -- ZERO THAT THAN
WE'VE HAD IN THE PAST.
SO -- YOU SORRY TO TOUCH ON SOME
OF THE STRATEGIES TO TRY TO MOVE
FASTER AND DEEPER AND AND YOU
GAVE US THE EXAMPLE SHORT TERM.
WHAT THE TRUCKS AND YOU GIVE US
THE EXAMPLE LONG TERM WITH
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE RAILWAY --
AND CITING THOSE ARE GOOD.
OF STARTING AND ENDING POINT
FOCUSES FOR MY NEXT QUESTION OF
WHAT'S WHAT'S IN THE IN BETWEEN
WHAT ARE SOME ADDITIONAL
STRATEGIES.
THAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO AND THIS --
MOBILE -- SECTOR PIECE WHETHER
IT'S CARS TRUCKS -- RATES.
OUR PLANES I MEAN YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT ARE SOME WHAT ARE SOME
OTHER THINGS IN IN THE INNER --
BECAUSE IN IN THE SHORT TERM --
THE TRUCKS.
HAVING TO HAVE.
BEEN COMPLAINTS AGAINST
REGISTRATION I THINK WE'LL HAVE
SOME POSITIVE EFFECTS IN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE.
BUT I DON'T THINK IT'LL BEING
FAST ENOUGH DEEP ENOUGH RIGHT
AND SO WHAT ELSE ARE WE GOING TO
BE DOING IN THERE WHAT ARE SOME
OF THE OTHER THINGS THAT YOU.
THAT AIR BE THROUGH THE STATE OR
THROUGH OTHER AVENUES IS
STARTING TO LOOK INTO SHORT IN
THE INTERIM.
SO WE'VE BEEN LOOKING WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH REGIONAL AIR
DISTRICTS I HAD -- TO FINDING
WAYS TO BRING WAREHOUSES AND
OTHER STATIONARY FACILITIES.
IN TO THE INTO THE STATUS OF
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY -- FOR
MAKING SURE THAT THEY ARE
ATTRACTING AND USING THE
CLEANEST POSSIBLE EQUIPMENT --
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO NOT SITE FACILITIES IN PLACES
WHERE THEY WILL -- BE CAUSING
UNDUE IMPACT ON THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES -- GETTING MORE
EFFICIENT ABOUT THE WAY THAT WAY
MOVE GOODS AROUND WHICH REALLY
REQUIRES A MUCH CLOSER
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCIES
AND A MORE -- COHERENT -- LOOK
AT HOW WE SPEND OUR
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS TO MAKE
SURE THAT AS AS WE TRY TO DO
WITH OUR REGULATIONS THAT WE ARE
GETTING AS MUCH BANG AS POSSIBLE
OUT OF EVERY BUCK THAT THE STATE
IS PAYING. TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S BEING UTILIZED.
FOR MAKING FACILITIES GREENER
AND HEALTHIER AT THE SAME TIME
AND THERE ARE TOOLS THAT ARE IN
WOULD SEEING DEMONSTRATIONS NOW
OF SOME OF THOSE IDEAS OUT THERE
IN THE REAL WORLD.
SOME OF THEM ARE JUST ON THE
DRAWING BOARDS AT THE MOMENT BUT
IT'S THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST
AND ACTIVITY I WOULD SAY AND THE
GOVERNOR I KNOW HAS SPOKEN ON
THIS TOPIC IN TERMS OF WARNING
HIS TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES --
TO PLAY A MORE -- ACTIVE AND
PROACTIVE ROLE IN LEADING ON
SOME OF THESE.
ARE THERE EXAMPLES RIGHT NOW OF
HELLO -- THE STATE AIR BE AT
THEIR TO THE STATE OR THROUGH
THE LOCAL -- DISTRICTS.
IS STARTING TO ENGAGE IN THOSE
TRANSPORTATION WITH THE
STRUCTURE TATIAN AGENCIES OR THE
LAND USE AGENCIES.
CURRENTLY.
YOU KNOW -- THERE WAS
LEGISLATION THAT PASSED AND I
WAS ARE FORGOTTEN THE BILL
NUMBER BUT THERE WAS A A
REQUIREMENT THAT WAS PASSED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO.
THAT -- THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
AND THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION HAVE
TO MEET TOGETHER SEVERAL TIMES A
YEAR THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT HAD
NEVER HAPPENED BEFORE -- AND THE
FIRST TIME OR TWO THAT WE MET
FRANKLY IT WAS PRETTY AWKWARD
BECAUSE WE OPERATE VERY
DIFFERENTLY ARE -- OUR APPROACH
TO ISSUES IS DIFFERENT THEY HAND
OUT LARGE AMOUNTS OF MONEY WITH
WHICH IS GREAT -- BUT DON'T
REGULATE AND THEY YOU KNOW.
BASICALLY TAKE PROJECTS THAT ARE
BROUGHT TO THEM AND ACT ON THEM
WHEREAS AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD WHERE MORE AND IN THE
BUSINESS OF DEVISING.
REGULATIONS AND SENDING THEM OUT
INTO THE WORLD SO THERE WERE
CULTURAL.
DIFFERENCES BUT THE LAST TIME WE
MET -- WE MET DOWN IN -- SAN
DIEGO AREA TO TALK ABOUT A
COMMON CONCERN WHICH IS THE FOR
THE FACT THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS LOOKING TO ROLL
BACK.
VEHICLE EMISSIONS STANDARDS
BECAUSE THAT ACTION COULD THROW
OUR REGION'S OUT OF COMPLIANCE
WITH THE CLEAN AIR ACT THEY
WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE TO SHOW
THAT THEY WERE COMPLYING WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS THAT THEY'RE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS -- ARE IN
CONFORMITY WITH THEIR AIR PLANS
AND SO TOGETHER -- WE HAVE BEEN
OUT EDUCATING PEOPLE AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN PARTICULARLY
ACTIVE -- IN CONGRESS BY
EDUCATING THEIR MEMBERS ABOUT
THE FACT THAT.
THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT GLOBAL
WARMING THIS IS ALSO WHAT ABOUT
AIR POLLUTION IF THE IF THE
VEHICLES ARE NOT.
MEANING THESE EMISSIONS
STANDARDS IT WILL HAVE THE
EFFECT OF UNDERCUTTING OUR
ABILITY TO MEET THOSE STANDARDS
SO -- THIS IS NOW A THREAT TO
CONSTRUCTION IT'S A THREAT TO
ACT YOU KNOW ONGOING ACTIVITIES
THAT PROGRAM FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS AND SO --
WE'RE NOW AT A MUCH MORE.
ACTIVE AND EFFECTIVE
COLLABORATION THAN WE HAD EVER
BEEN BEFORE BETWEEN THE AIR AND
THE TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES AND
I'M SURE THERE ARE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES TO DO MORE.
WHEN WHEN WAS THAT LAST MEETING?
I WAS JUST A MONTH OR SO AGO.
THE SOFT LITTLE START TO TRICKLE
DOWN TO THE LOCAL FOLKS IN --
THERE'S I MEAN I WILL SAY THAT.
I GO HOME AND AND WHILE WE I
HAVE A LOT OF PRIDE IN THE AB
SIX SEVENTEEN WORK THAT WE AND
THE BILL WE PASSED WITH THAT AB.
THREE NINETY EIGHT I HAD A SURE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS WITH MY
CONSTITUENTS OF WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S GOING TO BE ENOUGH IT'S
GOING TO BE ENOUGH FAST ENOUGH --
WHETHER OR NOT IN EXCHANGE FOR
THAT WHAT WHAT WE'RE GETTING OR
NOT GETTING FROM CAPITATED IS
WORTH IT IS WORTH THE TRADE OFF.
I AND AND THAT'S A QUESTION THAT
TIME GOING TO BE ANSWERED
ANYTIME SOON RIGHT WE HAVE TO
WAIT TO SEE.
WHAT THE DATA TELLS US?
ALONG THE WAY BUT IRRESPECTIVE
OF THAT THING WITH THE SENTIMENT
OF OF WHETHER WERE INTRACTABLE --
TWENTY THIRTY HOLD HER TWENTY
FIFTY GOALS AND AND THE FACT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS YET.
THERE'S A DISCUSSION OF MAYBE WE
DO HAVE THE TOOLS BUT WE HAVEN'T
HAD THE POLITICAL WILL TO USE
THEM -- THERE'S BEEN DISCUSSION
ABOUT INDIRECT SOURCE RULES --
ACROSS THE STATE IN SOME REGIONS
ARE MORE OPEN TO THAT THAN THAN
OTHERS -- WE TALK ABOUT
WAREHOUSES RIGHT AND HAVING THEM
BE A PART OF THE DISCUSSION AND
THEIR ROLE OF WITHIN THEIR
ACCESS RULES AS THEY ARE THESE
MAGNETS.
OUT THERE OR THE FAILURE TO HAVE
A RAIL YARD WITH TWO OPERATOR
SOMEONE THAT TURNS AWAY TRUCKS
THAT ARE NOT.
IN COMPLIANCE AND ONE THAT JUST
SENT TO LIST TO THEIR DISTRICT
AND I'M NOT SURE HOW HOW GREAT
OF A STRATEGY THAT IS RIGHT AND
HOW DO WE GET THEM TO ACTUALLY
MAYBE TURN AWAY AND DO THEIR
PART THAT WAY -- AND SO I THINK
WE KNOW THAT WHERE WERE NOT.
ON TRACK FOR THE LONG TURNS OF
TWENTY FIFTY GOALS BUT THERE IS
THAT QUESTION OF DO WE HAVE
TOOLS OUT THERE THAT WE MAYBE.
SHOULD BE IS AND HAVING BEEN
USING TO GET US ON TRACK AND
MAYBE GET US ON TRACK QUICKER
AND SOMEBODY'S COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE THE MOST IMPACTED -- DO YOU
HAVE ANY OPINIONS ON THAT.
WELL IT YOU KNOW IT IT'S SO BUT
IT'S GREAT TO BE.
AT A POINT NOW WHERE PEOPLE ARE
ASKING EVEN SOME OF THESE
QUESTIONS BECAUSE HAVING STARTED
WORK AS THAT.
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATE BACK IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN WE
WERE SUING TO BLOCK NEW FREEWAY
IS THAT WERE BEING PLANNED -- TO
GO THROUGH LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
ACCESS THAT'S WHERE THE LAND WAS
THE CHEAPEST AND NO
CONSIDERATION OF TRANSIT AS A
ALTERNATIVE TO JUST TRYING TO
BUILD MORE AND MORE LANES OF
FREEWAYS.
IT'S TAKEN A LONG TIME -- TO GET
CALIFORNIA I THINK TO THINK OF
ITSELF AS A PLACE WHERE WE WOULD
WANT TO LOOK AT MORE DENSITY --
IN THAT USED TO BE SORT OF A
DIRTY WORD THERE WAS AT
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCACY GROUP IN
LA WHEN I FIRST STARTED WORKING
THERE CALLED.
NOT YET NEW YORK AND THEIR GOAL
IN LIFE WAS TO PREVENT APARTMENT
BUILDINGS FROM BEING BUILT IN
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT WERE FORMERLY
ONLY YEAH YOU KNOW SINGLE STORY --
COMMUNITY SO -- WE'RE CHANGING
OUR IDEAS I THINK ABOUT WHAT'S
POSSIBLE OF WHAT'S DESIRABLE.
AND IT'S NOT COMING ONLY OUT OF
CONCERN FOR AIR QUALITY
CERTAINLYOR FOR A CLIMATE
CHANGE BUT IT THESE THINGS DO
WORK TOGETHER THE FACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE NOW SO.
VISIBLE AN OBVIOUS AROUND OUR
STATE.
MEANS THAT PEOPLE ARE LOOKING
FOR MAYBE MORE RADICAL SOLUTIONS
AT LEAST WILLING TO CONSIDER
THEM.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE LOOKING
FOR THOSE KINDS SOLUTIONS.
WE SHOULD BE DOING IT THOUGH NOT
JUST YOU KNOW AS A RB BUT REALLY
ACROSS STATE GOVERNMENT TO
WHEREVER.
WE HAVE EITHER MONEY THAT WE'RE
SPENDING OR WAY IS THAT WHERE.
ENABLING OF PRACTICES TO
CONTINUE THAT ARE UNHEALTHY WE
SHOULD BE LOOKING FOR WAYS TO
TURN THAT AROUND AND I'M.
EXCITED THAT YOU'RE INTERESTED
IN THAT.
YEAH AND AND I THINK YOU KNOW WE
HAVE -- THAT WE'RE THERE YET ON
ON THE DENSITY.
BUT WE HAVE MEMBERS ARE STARTING
TO ASK THE QUESTION AT LEAST A
LEGISLATURE THAT'S BEING
INTRODUCED.
ARE AROUND THAT -- I MEAN AND SO
YOU REFERENCE -- HE SAID THAT
NOTS IS THERE BE BUT OTHER
AGENCIES OR OTHER AREAS WILL
WHAT WHAT ARE SOME EXAMPLES YOU
HAVE FOR THAT.
WELL I MEAN EVEN WITH AND CAL
EPA IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
DISCOVERED THAT YOU KNOW WE
COULD BE WORKING MUCH MORE
CLOSELY THAN WE USED TO IN THE
PAST WITH THE WITH THE
INTEGRATED WASTE.
FOLKS -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOTHING EVER REALLY JUST BECOMES
A WASTE OF THAT WE RE USE OR
FIND WAYS TO AVOID TO THROWING
AWAY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THINGS -- THAT OTHERWISE YOU'RE
GONNA TAKE ENERGY AND BECAUSE
POLLUTION IF THEY IF THEY ARE
WASTE AND A SO A BIG PART OF THE
ANSWER -- TO MEETING ARE VERY
TOUGH.
GOALS REALLY HAS BEEN LOOKING
FOR WAYS BETTER IDEAS AND
TECHNOLOGIES FOR HOW TO MANAGE
WASTE IN OUR SOCIETY -- THERE'S
A LOT OF TALK NOW ABOUT FOOD AND
HOW IT'S PRODUCED AND HOW IT IS --
BROUGHT TO MARKET AND JUST
RECENTLY WE BEGAN WORKING WITH
THE CALLIE PA OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD.
CULTURE ON A PROGRAM IN WHICH
PEOPLE WHO EAT OUT IN
RESTAURANTS CAN -- PAY A TINY
AMOUNT EXTRA ON THEIR TRACK AND
HAVE THAT MONEY GO BACK -- TO
FARMS TO PAY -- FOR PEOPLE TO
USE THE METHODOLOGIES FOR
FARMING THAT PRODUCE LESS
EMISSIONS AND TO ENGAGE IN OUT
THINGS LIKE WHAT THEY CALLED NO
TILL AGRICULTURE WERE YOU AVOID --
RELEASING RELEASING CARBON THAT
STORED IN THE SOIL BUT IT COSTS
MORE MONEY FOR THE FARMERS TO DO
IT SO IT'S A IT'S A KIND OF A
VIRTUOUS CIRCLE INSTEAD OF A
VICIOUS CIRCLE TO DO SOMETHING.
LIKE THAT WHERE PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN HELPING TO MAKE
THE FOOD PRODUCTION PROCESS MORE
EFFICIENT AND THERE'S THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF IDEAS LIKE THAT
OUT THERE THAT WE NEED TO BE.
LOOKING AT AND FINDING WAYS TO
IMPLEMENT.
OKAY -- I'M GOING.
TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT -- US.
SECTION OF OF TODAY BECAUSE THEY
DO WANT TO TRY TO KEEP US ON
SCHEDULE -- THANK YOU FOR FOR
YOUR TIME I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN
BUSY PLANE HOW OFTEN IS OUT
THERE AND YOUR TIME IS FOR
BETWEEN BEING ERE AND BEING.
OUT OF THE OUT OF THE STATE AS I
WANT TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT BUT I
I DO WANT TO RE ITERATE.
THE IMPORTANCE IN THE POWER THAT
I FEEL THAT THEY'RE A STATE OR
DISTRICT PASSES SOMETIMES
PUSHING ALONG OUR LOCAL ARE
DISTRICTS.
TO MAYBE ARE NOT AS PROGRESSIVE
AS WE NEED THEM TO BE HI IN
LOOKING AT WAYS BEYONCE'S
HANDING OUT MONEY.
BUT ALSO USING THE POWER THEY
HAVE WITH THE SPICE AND
REGULATIONS AND HAVING THE
COURAGE TO DO.
WHAT'S RIGHT TO WE CAN MOVE
FASTER AND DEEPER FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE.
BEEN SO UNFAIRLY BURDEN AND
CONTINUE TO BE.
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT THE
GROWING ECONOMY AROUND THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR AND I I
KNOW THAT'S A DELICATE BALANCE
SOME OF THOSE ARE.
WE HAVE GOOD JOB SIR THERE ARE
IMPORTANT PART OF THE ECONOMY
BUT I CAN'T KEEP COMING AT THE
EXPENSE OF CERTAIN COMMUNITIES I
GET TREATED LIKE THEIR
DISPOSABLE OR THEIR BACKYARDS
ARE WASTELANDS AND SO -- I THINK
AS WE TALK ABOUT EQUITY THESE
ARE REAL PEOPLE REAL PEOPLE THAT
I GO HOME.
TO EVERY WEEK -- AND I KEEP
TELLING THEM THAT THE MATTER
JUST AS MUCH AS THE FOLKS IN
OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT ARE NOT
US IMPACTED IN.
AND HAVE THE RESOURCES TO HELP
THEMSELVES THAT WHEN THERE IS A
CRISIS BECAUSE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE ARE BECAUSE OF POLLUTION.
OUT THERE ARE AND SO I HOPE I DO
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE I HOPE --
THAT AS YOU DO THE LOCAL WORK AS
YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR US OUT THERE --
AT AND AT THE NATIONAL SIDE OF
THINGS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PRESSURE THE LOCAL ARE DISTRICTS
TO DO BETTER BY THESE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES ARE GOING TO BE
HEARING FROM.
A COUPLE OF SPEAKERS TODAY ABOUT
SOME OF THESE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES AND I MAY CHANGE
OTHER AFFECTED AND AND HOW
THEY'RE AT A BIGGER THIS
ADVANTAGE AND IN THESE CRISIS
OUT THERE AND HOW WE NEED TO
TAKE ACTION.
QUICKER AND AND HAVE THE COURAGE
HI SO I LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
ADDITIONAL IDEAS YOU MIGHT HAVE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO DO YOU IN
TO HELP YOU A CHAMPION FOR SOME
OF THOSE IDEAS. TO TO MOVE US
TOWARD HER TWENTY FIFTY GOALS
AND DO IT IN A WAY WHERE WE HELP
THESE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE THE
MOST DISADVANTAGED SOONER THAN
LATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN I WOULD JUST ASK YOU TO
STICK AROUND IN CASE WE HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS LATER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ON INTO NEXT UP WE ARE GOING TO
HAVE A THREE PRESS CENTERS
PERCENT TO A SIX ARE EXAMPLES OF
SIGNIFICANT.
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION PEGS
IMPACTS ON VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES.
AT WE ARE GOING TO BE STARTING
WITH DOCTOR STEPHEN WHEELER
PROFESSOR OF THE UNIVERSITY.
OF CALIFORNIA AT DAVIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HAVING ME TODAY --
PROFESSOR RULER LET ME GIVE YOU
THIS A LITTLE BIT OF ACTUALLY TO
FOR A START OKAY -- I THINK YOU
FOR MAKING TIME OUT HERE MISTER
WHEELER IS A PROFESSOR IN THE
LANDSCAPE ARCHITECTURE PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN ECOLOGY
AT UC DAVIS -- AND HE IS -- HE'S
THE AUTHOR OF THREE BOOKS
PLANNING FOR SUSTAINABILITY
TOWARDS CIVIL EQUITABLE AND
ECOLOGICAL COMMUNITIES I AND HE
WILL BE TALKING TO US TODAY
ABOUT URBAN COMMUNITY SAID THIS
EVENT IS A THANK YOU FOR MAKING
TIME.
YOU HAVE HIS BIO AND THEN SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION OF THE
LEADERSHIP THAT HE'S OUT THERE
DOING -- IN THIS AREA BUT I I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR MAKING
TIME AND I'M EXCITED TO HEAR
YOUR COMMENTS TODAY THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I AM
NOT GOING TO SPEAK ABOUT
MEDICATION ALTHOUGH I AM VERY
HAPPY TO MAKE A FEW COMMENTS
ABOUT THAT LATER I AM INSTEAD
GOING TO TALK ABOUT HE IMPACT.
ON VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AND
WAYS TO POSSIBLY REDUCE THOSE.
OVER THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS I'VE
DONE RESEARCH LOOKING AT URBAN
HEAT ISLANDS.
IN ARID AND SEMI ARID REGIONS
WORLDWIDE.
THIS TOPIC IS IMPORTANT TO
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE PLANNING.
FOR REASONS THAT I THINK WE ALL
KNOW OUR COMMUNITIES WILL GET
HOTTER.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY HE WILL BE
GREATER SOME PLACES THAN OTHERS.
AND THEY WILL BE PUBLIC HEALTH
IMPACT STAY WILL THERE WILL BE
INCREASED MORTALITY VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES WILL SUFFER THE MOST
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY PUBLIC
POLICY PUT IN PLACE NOW.
CAN POTENTIALLY REDUCE THESE
IMPACTS SOMEWHAT AND DISPARITIES
BETWEEN COMMUNITIES.
NOW THE PHENOMENON OF URBAN HEAT
ISLANDS.
HAS GOTTEN A LOT OF PRESS IN THE
LAST DECADE THIS IS THE FOR NOT
WELL KNOWN PHENOMENA IN WHICH
URBAN LANDSCAPES DOMINATED BY.
ASPHALT AND ROOFTOPS.
HEAT UP DURING THE DAY MORE
STRONGLY THAN SURROUNDING RURAL
REGIONS.%
THIS IS NOT A NEW PHENOMENON IT
HAS BEEN KNOWN ABOUT SINCE THE
NINETEENTH CENTURY THERE'S BEEN.
ACADEMIC STUDY SINCE NINETEEN
SIXTIES.
IT HAS INCREASED THOUGH QUITE A
BIT AS COMMUNITIES RURAL URBAN
REGIONS HAVE GROWN.
IN TEMPERATE CLIMATES CITIES CAN
BE FIVE TO TEN DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT HOTTER ON A WARM
SUMMER DAY.
THEN SURROUNDING COUNTRYSIDE.
BUT WHAT ISN'T AS WELL KNOWN IS
THAT SOME NEIGHBORHOODS WITH IN
BOTH CITIES AND SMALLER RURAL
TOWNS.
WE'LL BE MUCH HOTTER THAN OTHERS.
MY OWN WORK HAS FOUND THAT ON A
JULY DAY YOU THE HOTTEST BUILT
LANDSCAPES WITH IN SACRAMENTO
ARE.
UP TO NINETY DEGREES HOTTER
WARMER DâN COOLEST THE COOLEST
NEIGHBORHOODS A PLACE LIKE A
LONG FLOOR IN BOULEVARD WILL BE
ABOUT. NINE DEGREES HOTTER THAN
IN LAND PARK WHICH IS LESS THAN
A MILE AWAY.
THESE ARE SURFACE TEMPERATURES I
SHOULD MENTION AIR TEMPERATURES
WILL BE SOMEWHAT LESS OF A
DIFFERENCE BUT STILL SIGNIFICANT.
RESEARCHERS INITIALLY STUDIED
URBAN HEAT ISLANDS IN TEMPERATE
CITIES SUCH AS ATLANTA WHICH IS
ONE OF THE CLASSIC.
CASES.
END WHEN YOU HAVE SURROUNDING
RURAL AREAS THAT ARE HEAVILY
FORESTED.
THOSE STAY MUCH COOLER THAN THE
CITY.
MUCH MORE RECENTLY WE AT THOSE
OF US IN ACADEMIA HAVE.
END RECENT WORK HAS FOUND THAT.
HEAT ISLANDS.
IN THESE PLACES IS ARE MUCH MORE
COMPLEX THAN FOR TRIAL AND THEN
FOR TEMPERATURE.
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
VEGETATION DESERT AND OTHER DRY
RURAL LANDSCAPES HEAT UP MUCH
MORE RAPIDLY DURING THE DAY.
ENDS BUT ALSO COOL DOWN MUCH
MORE RAPIDLY AT NIGHT STAND
DEMONSTRATED FOR EXAMPLE BY
MADRID WHICH IS ON THE RIGHT
HERE AT THE BLUE OBVIOUSLY ARC
IS COOL AND THEN THE LEFT YOU
SEE THERE IS WHAT'S CALLED AN
URBAN COOL ISLAND DURING THE DAY.
AND AT NIGHT WE HAVE AN URBAN
HEAT ISLAND -- ENDS THESE
PHENOMENA ARE ALSO AFFECTED BY
ELEVATION HUMIDITY THE PRESENCE
OF MOUNTAINS OCEANS AND OTHER.
OTHER THINGS.
SINCE URBAN HEAT ISLAND IN ARID
REGIONS DO HAVE THIS COMPLEX
NATURE.
WE MAKES MOST SENSE IN
CALIFORNIA TO JUST FOCUS ON HEAT.
RATHER THAN HEAT ISLANDS PER SE.
EVEN THOUGH HE ISLANDS DOES
SOUND LIKE A TRENDY TOPIC.
END TO LOOK AT POLICIES AND
PROGRAMS TO REDUCE TEMPERATURES
IN THE HOTTEST AND MOST
VULNERABLE NEIGHBORHOODS.
SO HERE IS A KEEP MAPPING OF THE
LA BASIN [inaudible]
END.
WE CAN SEE THAT SOME AREAS ARE
MUCH HARDER THAN OTHERS THE
COAST OBVIOUSLY IS USUALLY
COOLER.
OF WE HAVE SOME INTERESTING
PHENOMENA AT NIGHT IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE IS A BIT OF A HEAT ISLAND
IN THE LONG BEACH AREA.
I DON'T KNOW WHY THAT IS IT
COULD BE SOMETHING TO DO WITH
PREVAILING WINDS OR NEARBY
INDUSTRIAL AREAS OR WHATEVER
[inaudible]
A BUNCH.
OUR GOAL IN THE FUTURE I THINK
HE'S GOING TO NEED TO BE TO
UNDERSTAND THESE DYNAMICS AND TO
NOT JUST DO A ONE DAY MAPPING
BUT TO MODEL IT THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR. TO IDENTIFY THE AREAS THAT
ARE REALLY HOTTER.
THAN OTHERS IN NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT ARE AT MOST RISK OF HEAT.
TO OVERLAY THAT WITH THE NASCENT
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE MOST
VULNERABLE BECAUSE OF POVERTY OR
BECAUSE OF PRESENCE OF ELDERLY
OR VERY YOUNG POPULATIONS OR
OTHER.
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS AND THEN
DEVELOP STRATEGIES.
TO REDUCE THE RISK -- IN SUCH
ANALYSES CAN BE DONE FOR BOTH
RURAL AND URBAN COMMUNITIES.
SO HE'S HAS PARTICULAR IMPACTS
ON DISADVANTAGED POPULATIONS.
HOUSEHOLDS WITHOUT GOOD AIR
CONDITIONING OR EVAPORATIVE
COOLERS WHICH IS TO SAY MANY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
HAVE LITTLE RELIEF FROM HIGH
TEMPERATURES EVEN AT NIGHT --
PROLONGED HEAT IS HARD ON THE
ELDERLY AND OTHERS IN POOR
HEALTH LEADING TO INCREASED
MORTALITY.
PROLONGED HEAT CAN ALSO BE HARD
ON THE VERY YOUNG.
I SPEAK FROM SOME PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE ON THIS SINCE MY
DAUGHTER SENT SUFFERED FROM
FEBRILE SEIZURES I II
CONVULSIONS THAT OCCUR BECAUSE
OF HIGH BODY TEMPERATURES.
WHICH ARE MOST COMMON BETWEEN
SIX MONTHS AND FIVE YEARS OF AGE.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND THREE
HEAT WAVE IN FRANCE WHICH IS
WHAT THE GRAPH YOUR SHOWS.
SOME FIFTEEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
DIED PREMATURELY AND I THINK THE
NUMBER FOR EUROPE AS A WHOLE WAS
CLOSER.
TO SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
PROBABLY THE CURRENT EUROPEAN
HEAT WAVE WILL HAVE SIMILAR
RESULTS.
AND YOU SEE THE MORTALITY GOES
UP OVER TIME IS PEOPLE'S
RESILIENCE.
WAS DOWN AFTER AN EXTENDED
PERIOD OF HEAT. TO DATE THERE
HAVE BEEN FEW IF ANY
NEIGHBORHOOD SCALE STUDIES
QUANTIFYING THE DISPROPORTIONATE
KEEP RELATED CLIMATE RISK.
FACED BY DISADVANTAGED
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES.
I HOPE TO UNDERTAKE. ONE SUCH
STUDY THIS FALL WITH ONE OF MY
GRADUATE STUDENTS AND MAYBE NEXT
YEAR WE WILL HAVE SOME BETTER
DATA.
HOWEVER WE DO ALREADY KNOW THAT
THESE COMMUNITIES WILL BE
VULNERABLE.
SO HOW DO WE KEEP CALIFORNIA
NEIGHBORHOODS COOL.
THERE ARE BASICALLY THREE MAIN
STRATEGIES. TO MAXIMIZE
VEGETATION ESPECIALLY AT LARGE
DROUGHT TOLERANT SHADE TREES. TO
MAKE SERVICES SUCH AS ROOFS AND
PAVING REFLECT RATHER THAN
ABSORB HEAT.
AND TO USE BUILDING FORM
TRELLISES AWNINGS AND OTHER
DESIGN STRATEGY. TO PRODUCE
SHADE FOR PEOPLE AT GROUND LEVEL.
THE STATE CAN PLAY A ROLE IN
HELPING ALL THREE STRATEGIES
COME ABOUT AND IT ALREADY DOES
IN SOME WAY.
SO LET'S TAKE THE FIRST OF THOSE.
GREENING COMMUNITIES IS NOT
SIMPLE IN A DRY CLIMATE.
ALTHOUGH THE COOL AIR THROUGH IF
APPLE TRANSPIRATION LAWNS ARE
USUALLY NOT DESIRABLE SINCE THEY
REQUIRE EXTENSIVE IRRIGATION.
AND DON'T PRODUCE SHAPE.
SHAPE PRODUCING TREES ARE A MUCH
BETTER STRATEGY.
THE CHALLENGE IS TO IDENTIFY
SPECIES.
THAT WILL MAXIMIZE SHADING WHILE
MINIMIZING WATER USE.
END TOLERATING HARSH CONDITIONS
THAT OFTEN OCCUR ALONG STREETS
AND IN PARKING LOTS.
THERE ARE USEFUL DATABASES THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN DEVELOPED.
THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURAL AND NATURAL
RESOURCES.
THIS CALL THAT WILL CALLS
DATABASE DON'T ASK ME TO
REMEMBER WHAT IT STANDS -- FOR
END THROUGH CAL POLY SAN LUIS
OBISPO IT'S CALLED THE SELECT
THREE DATABASE.
SOME OF THE STATE UTILITIES AND
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE ALSO TAKEN
LEADERSHIP IN PROMOTING URBAN
FORESTRY.
MANY CITIES ARE NOW REQUIRING
DEVELOPERS TO PLANT TREES IN
PARKING LOTS.
SO THAT AT LEAST 50% OF ASPHALT
SURFACES WE'LL BE SHADED IN TEN
YEARS.
CITIES COULD ALSO DEVELOP STREET
TREE PROGRAMS THAT WOULD SHAPE
STREETS A SIMILAR AMOUNT.
AND COULD ADOPT SUBDIVISION
CODES FOR NEW DEVELOPMENT.
THAT WOULD REQUIRE NARROWER
STREETS WITH LESS ASPHALT.
AND MORE EXTENSIVE SHADING.
POTENTIALLY THE STATE COULD
ENCOURAGE OR REQUIRE SUCH STEPS.
THE STATE HAS PROVIDED FUNDING
THROUGH WHICH URBAN GREENING
PROGRAM AND OTHER PROGRAMS. FOR
URBAN FORESTRY WHICH COULD BE
INCREASED IN THE FUTURE AS WELL.
MOVING ON TO THE SECOND TOPIC
CALIFORNIA HAS ALREADY MADE
STRIDES TOWARD REQUIRING COOL
ROOFS IN PART DUE TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF LATE C. C.
COMMISSIONER ART ROSENFELDT.
THE STATE'S BUILDING CODE NOW
REQUIRES ROOFING MATERIALS TO
HAVE RELATIVELY HIGH LEVELS OF
REFLECTANCE.
WHICH CAN BE ACHIEVED WITHOUT
NECESSARILY MAKING SHINGLES
WHITE OR EVEN LIGHT COLORED.
STREET SERVICES HAVE NOT
RECEIVED SO MUCH ATTENTION.
HOWEVER CANOGA PARK IS
EXPERIMENTING WITH LIGHT COLORED
ASPHALT THAT HAS HIGHER
REFLECTANCE.
AND THE STATE PERHAPS COULD
ACCELERATE EFFORTS ON THIS FRONT
AS WELL.
THE THIRD STRATEGY USING BUILT
FORM.
TO CREATE SHADE IS THE LEAST
EXPLORED TO DATE.
AND LET ME MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
LINE.
OF MEDITERRANEAN AND LATIN
AMERICAN CITIES HAVE USED THE
STRATEGY FOR CENTURIES.
HOWEVER IN CALIFORNIA WE'VE
OFTEN CREATED LOW SPREAD OUT
BUILT LANDSCAPES WITH LITTLE IF
ANY SHADE FOR PEDESTRIANS.
MUNICIPALITIES COULD REQUIRE NEW
BUILDINGS PARTICULARLY IN
CENTRAL LOCATIONS. TO BE AT
LEAST TWO OR THREE STORIES SO
THAT THEY CAST A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF SHADE.
AND THE COULD REQUIRE AWNINGS
WERE PORTICOS OVERSIGHT WALKS.
COURTYARDS ARE ALSO DESIRABLE
WITHIN LARGE BUILDINGS.
SINCE THEY ALMOST ALWAYS HAVE AT
LEAST ONE SIDE IN SHADE AND
CREATE RELATIVELY COOL OUTDOOR
MICRO CLIMATES FOR BUILDING
RESIDENTS.
THE STATE MIGHT ENCOURAGE SUCH
DESIGN STRATEGIES AS WELL AS
PASSIVE SOLAR ARCHITECTURE IN
GENERAL WHICH WOULD KEEP
BUILDINGS COOL WITHOUT EXCESSIVE
AIR CONDITIONING USE.
THROUGH THESE THREE AREAS URBAN
FORESTRY REFLECTIVE ROOF AND
PAVING MATERIALS AND SHAPE
PRODUCING BUILT FORM.
BOTH LOCAL AND STATE GOVERNMENTS
IN CALIFORNIA MIGHT TAKE
INITIATIVE TO REDUCE HEAT RISKS.
AT RISK LOW INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS
COULD RECEIVE SPECIAL PRIORITY
WITHIN SUCH PROGRAMS.
THE END RESULT.
WE'LL BE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES
BOTH RURAL AND URBAN THAT STAY
COOLER DURING THE NEXT CENTURY.
BY HAVING MORE CONTINUOUS.
TREE CANOPIES.
COOLER ROOFS AND PAVED SURFACES.
AND MORE GROUND LEVEL SHADE
CREATED BY BUILDINGS AND SHADE
STRUCTURES AND LET ME EMPHASIZE
AGAIN THIS CAN HAPPEN FOR SMALL
TOWNS AND RURAL PLACES AS WELL
AS CITIES.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN FOR INVITING
ME TO SPEAK TO YOU TODAY AND I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
AT THANK YOU DOCTOR MILLER -- SO.
WHEELER ACTUALLY WIENER.
MY APOLOGIES -- IT'S CORRECT IN
MY THE PAPER -- SAID I MEAN THE
THE PROMISES THAT.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS GOING TO
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF HEAT
WAVES WE'RE GONNA HAVE LONGER
HEAT WAVES.
AND COMMUNITIES -- THAT ARE
ALREADY DISADVANTAGE ARE GONNA.
BE THAT MUCH MORE IMPACTED ALONG
THE WAY.
HAVE YOU HAVE HAS YOUR RESEARCH
LOOKED A LITTLE BAR CLOSELY
SPECIFICALLY AT THAT CONNECTION
WITH GHGS SHE WITH REDUCTIONS
MEDICATION -- AND IF SO CAN YOU
GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE SPECIFICS
ON THAT.
OKAY I HAVE LOOKED TO SEPARATELY
AT MITIGATION STRATEGIES FOR
GREENHOUSE GASES.
AND IN PARTICULAR I HAVE DONE
SOME WORK WITH.
DAN KAMIN AND CHRIS JONES WHO
ARE AT UC BERKELEY.
AROUND.
CONSUMPTION BASED EMISSIONS OF
THERE IS.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS DONE
WONDERFUL WORK IN TERMS OF
CLIMATE MITIGATION PLANNING.
BUT THERE IS AN ELEPHANT IN THE
ROOM ON THAT.
ONE WHICH IS THAT WE DO NOT YET
HAVE A GOOD WAY.
OF INCLUDING EMISSIONS THAT
RESULT FROM OUR CONSUMPTION
STUFF WE BUY AND STUFF WE EAT.
AND A LOT OF THOSE EMISSIONS ARE
IN EFFECT EXPORTED TO CHINA OR
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD
[inaudible]
SO.
ACTUAL CALIFORNIA MISSIONS ARE
PROBABLY 30% HIGHER THAN WHAT WE
NOW -- ARE TALKING ABOUT.
IN THE LONG RUN I THINK PROBABLY
THE MORE COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH
WILL BE TO GET THOSE IN IN SOME
WAYS THAT INCLUDES DIET VERY
MUCH AS WELL AS HOUSEHOLD
PURCHASES.
AND IT ALSO INCLUDES THINGS LIKE
AIR TRAVEL WHICH ARE NOT WILL
INCORPORATED CURRENTLY
[inaudible]
END -- IT WILL REQUIRE SOCIAL
MARKETING CAMPAIGNS TO MAKE THE
PUBLIC AWARE OF THE IMPACT OF
THESE THINGS.
IT WILL REQUIRE BETTER.
PROCESS SEES OF FIGURING OUT
EMBODIED EMISSIONS IN PRODUCT.
OF THINGS THAT WE BUY AND
CONSUME.
THAT IS COMING ALONG QUITE
RAPIDLY -- END IT WILL REQUIRE --
LOT OF EDUCATION AND POLITICAL
MESSAGING.
WHICH I THINK WE ARE NOT YET
REALLY.
OF BEGINNING TO GET INTO.
THANK YOU BEFORE -- I PROCEED I
DO WANT TO LIE TO HAVE SENATOR
WITH SO HERE WITH US.
A TWO DAY AND BEFORE I ASK MY
NEXT QUESTION DO YOU HAVE.
ANY QUESTION YOURSELF FOR DOCTOR
MILLER.
AT OKAY THANK YOU -- IN THE LOST
MY TRAIN OF THOUGHT HERE BUT I
ME MYSELF AND OUT.
UP ABOUT THIS SHOOT.
I'LL GO AHEAD AND JUST UP.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL OFTENTIMES.
ENTRIES IN THE GROUND IS NOT THE
CHALLENGE IS KEEPING THEM ALIVE.
AND WHEN YOU GO TO RESIDENTS AND
ASK THEM TO PARTNER.
WITH YOU AND SAY WE'LL GIVE YOU
A FREE TRIP TO CREATE A WATER IT
MOST PEOPLE WHILE.
MOST PEOPLE WON'T AGREE TO THAT
IT'S VERY INTERESTING SOME WILL
SOME WALTON THAT PRESENTS
CHALLENGES AND THE OTHER ISSUE.
IS AS HAVING TO DO WITH -- ARE
DWINDLING FOREST ESPECIALLY IN
THE SOUTH.
WE'VE HAD WILD FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE DECIMATED --
PINE FORESTS.
IN THE AREAS OF KIND THE
HIGHLANDS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
SCIENTISTS HAVE -- OF HAVE
PROGNOSTICATOR THAT.
THESE TREES WILL NEVER RECOVER
NATURALLY [inaudible]
AND WHICH ONE WOULDN'T.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL IT'S HARD TO
GET THESE TREES ADOPTED IN
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
[inaudible]
LOW VEGETATION.
AND IN OUR FORESTS WERE HAVING A
HARD TIME REINTRODUCING -- A
DENT IN NOT REGRET JUST
REPLACING FORCE THAT WE'VE LOST
[inaudible]
AND AND YOU KNOW WHEN I'VE WHEN
I'VE -- STUDIED HISTORY.
IN FIFTEEN EN I'M SORRY AND YES
OF FIFTEEN FORTY TWO WHAT WHEN
CUANDO REDISCOVERY OF SAILED UP
THE CALIFORNIA COAST.
HE FOUND OF MONTEREY PINES.
OFF THE COAST OF GATORADE --
NEGATIVE WHICH IS MADE PENINSULA
BAJA CALIFORNIA.
NOW THE ONLY MONTEREY PINES THAT
EXIST ARE OUT SOME ISLANDS
CALDWELL BALANCE AND THAT'S KIND
OF A REMNANT OF A VERY LUSH
FORESTS THAT USED TO BE COASTAL
FORCED.
AND WE'RE LOSING THAT LITTLE BY
LITTLE [inaudible]
HAVE YOU.
CONSIDER THAT IN YOUR IN YOUR
STUDIES HOW DO WE COMBAT.
THE THE THE CONTINUE DOES THIS
EFFORT.
DESERT IF THE CATION.
OF OUR STATE.
I MEAN WHEN WE LOOK AT CLIMATE
CHANGE S. IS VERY HARSH.
ON PINE WOOD FORESTS.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT OF THE NATIVE
SPECIES OF CALIFORNIA THOUGH
COASTAL LIVE OAK.
EVEN THOSE ARE THREATEN ACROSS
OUR STATE.
WHAT DO WE WHAT DO WE INTRODUCE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES TO REPLACE
WHAT IS NATIVE?
THAT IS A VERY GOOD QUESTION.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE ANSWERS TO
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
MOUNTAIN FORCE IS GOING TO BE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT HAPPENS IN
URBAN.
STREETS.
WE MAY NEED TO GET AWAY FROM.
NATIVE.
I AM A BIGOT IS BIG A FAN AS
ANYONE OF NATIVE LANDSCAPES BUT
LET'S FACE IT IN THE FUTURE.
THEY WILL BE DIFFERENT AND WE
MAY NEED TO LOOK AT PLACES LIKE
AUSTRALIA TO LOOK FOR DROUGHT
TOLERANT SPECIES THAT WILL WORK
HERE NOW.
IN THE NINETEENTH CENTURY A LOT
OF EUCALYPTUS WERE IMPORTED FROM
AUSTRALIA AND WE DON'T WANT TO
REPEAT THAT THAT DID NOT.
ALWAYS WORK WELL BUT THERE MAY
BE OTHER SPECIES THAT.
COULD WORK AND WE NEED TO BE
EXTREMELY CAREFUL ABOUT
TRANSPORTING SPECIES ANYWHERE.
BUT LET'S FACE IT OUR CLIMATE
MAY BE CLOSER TO THE WEST COAST
OF AUSTRALIA IN FIFTY YEARS DâN
IT WILL BE TO WHAT CALIFORNIA
USED TO BE -- LA HAD A MILLION
TREE PROGRAM THAT BEGAN IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX THAT ARM.
HAD MIXED SUCCESS AND DID NOT
ACHIEVE ANYTHING LIKE A MILLION
TREES AS FAR AS I KNOW.
OF THEY SOMETHING'S WORKED WELL
BUT THEY CHOSE SOME SPECIES THAT
DID REQUIRE.
A FAIR BIT WATER.
AND THOSE DIDN'T WORK.
SO WE NEED TO BE A LITTLE MORE
JUDICIOUS ABOUT WHICH PIECES WE
ACTUALLY CHOOSE.
OF WE MAY NEED.
TO LOOK AT ST DESIGNED
DIFFERENTLY SO THAT THE RUNOFF
FROM STREETS AND PARKING LOTS.
IS HELD LOCALLY FOR THE TREES.
AND PERHAPS EVEN GRAY WATER FROM
BUILDINGS-- WE MAY WANT TO
THINK HOLISTICALLY ABOUT WATER
SYSTEMS SO THAT WE USE EVERY
DROP THAT WE HAVE MORE
EFFECTIVELY AND WE USE IT AND
REUSE IT [inaudible] FOR
VEGETATION [inaudible]
OF BUT IN SOME CASES.
WE MAY NOT HAVE THAT MUCH
VEGETATION I USED TO WORK IN
STATE OF NEW MEXICO WHICH IS
MORE ARID IN MANY PLACES THAT
CALIFORNIA -- THERE ARE NO LARGE
NATIVE TREE SPECIES [inaudible]
IN.
ALBUQUERQUE WHERE I USED TO LIVE
OUTSIDE OF THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY
WHICH IS.
A UNIQUE CASE.
SO IS A BIG QUESTION WHAT WE DO --
NOW THERE THERE DEFINITELY ARE
SOME DESERT SPECIES THAT HAVE
THAT TAKE VERY LITTLE WATER.
THE USUALLY AREN'T AS DEEP AS
SHAPE BUT THE DE ELEMENTARY.
THEY ARE USEFUL AND THAT'S WHERE
THE BILL FOR CONSENT TO WE NEED
TO CREATE CHAIRED IN COMMUNITIES%
AND IN A PLACES THE
MEDITERRANEAN HAVE KNOWN THIS
FOR MILLENNIA.
BUT WE NEED TO RETHINK THE LOOK
AND FEEL PERHAPS OF CALIFORNIA
TOWNS.
A BIT IN ORDER TO BE COMFORTABLE
AND HEALTHY.
THANK YOU -- MY LAST QUESTION
WAS WE WERE LOOKING AT RURAL
VERSUS URBAN COMMUNITIES AND HE
HE THEIR LANDS.
ARE THERE RECOMMENDATIONS OF I
THESE RECOMMENDATIONS SIMILAR --
TO FIGHT THE IMPACTS FOR A ROLE
AND ARE BETTER THE HAVE SET
SEPARATE STRATEGIES THAT YOU
RECOMMEND.
WELL IN MANY ARE THE SAME --
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE SOME
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS FARM WORK IN
RURAL AREAS THAT WILL HAVE
PARTICULAR NEEDS. TO PROTECT
FARMWORKERS AND THAT DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN URBAN PLACES -- BUT AS
FAR AS THE TOWNS THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW THE IT'S THE SAME
CHALLENGE.
HOW DO YOU KEEP?
PEOPLE'S DWELLINGS COMFORTABLE
PEOPLE'S TRAVEL OUTDOORS
COMFORTABLE -- SO IT'S NOT
RADICALLY DIFFERENT.
I WILL MENTION ONE OTHER THING
ON MEDICATION I DO TEACH LAND
USE PLANNING AND TRANSPORTATION
PLANNING AND THE OTHER ONE OTHER
BIG PIECE OF THE MEDICATION
PICTURE THAT HASN'T WORKED RULES
WELL SO FAR IS SB.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE AND ONE OF
THE STUDIES HAS NOT WHERE IT HAS
NOT WORKED -- BASICALLY LOCAL
METROPOLITAN PLANNING
ORGANIZATIONS HAVE OFTEN SIMPLY
REBRANDED THEIR EXISTING
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLAN AS
A SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES PLAN
WITHOUT REALLY THINKING IT
THROUGH.
WHAT ALL THE DIFFERENT
DIMENSIONS OF THAT WOULD BE?
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS WE KNOW
THEM DON'T HAVE. TO COMPLY WITH
THE REGIONAL PLANS THAT ARE DONE
IN TERMS OF LAND USE -- SO THE
COMPLAINTS HAS BEEN PRETTY
SPOTTY.
SO I THINK WE NEED SOMETHING --
SECOND GENERATION ON THAT WHICH
GOES QUITE A BIT FURTHER
[inaudible]
INFILL DEVELOPMENT. FOR PLACES
THAT LEAD TO WERE YOU CAN LEAVE
A LOW CARBON LIFESTYLE.
DOES PRODUCE PRETTY GOOD RESULTS
IN TERMS OF REDUCING EMISSIONS.
IF YOU DO IT IN OUTLYING TOWNS
THAT.
WHERE IT'S NOT SO EASY TO LIVE
WITHOUT A CAR OR WITHOUT RICK
LONG DISTANCE COMMUTING?
IT DOESN'T MATTER AS MUCH BUT WE
DO WANT INFILL TO HAPPEN AND WE
NEED SOME MORE INCENTIVES FOR IT
TO HAPPEN AND WE NEED IT TO
HAPPEN WITHOUT GENTRIFICATION
AND DISPLACEMENT IF POSSIBLE SO
I KNOW THAT'S A BIG.
ORDER BUT HAPPY TO TALK TO THAT
IF YOU WANT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WITH VARYING
GAVE US SOME HOMEWORK AT LOOKING
AT SB THREE SEVENTY FIVE IN A
FUTURE ITERATION POSSIBLY OF
THAT -- I DO APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME -- AND SYNNEX WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TURN EXPRESS CENTER
TODAY WE HAVE MARGARET GORDON
WHO IS OUR WEST OAKLAND
ENVIRONMENTAL -- INDICATORS CO
FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR.
THE NONPROFIT THAT WORKS WITH
NEIGHBORHOOD ORGANIZATIONS
ASSISTANCE RESEARCHERS AND
PUBLIC OFFICIALS TO ENSURE WITH
OAKLAND RESIDENTS HAVE A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT.
THEY'VE NEVER HOODS AND ACCESS
TO ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY.
AND SO I DO APPRECIATE YOU
MAKING TIME FOR US TO DAY AND
EXCITED HERE -- YOUR
PRESENTATION FROM KERN.
OUR FIRST THOUGHT MY NAME IS
MISS MARGARET I'M SEVENTY TWO
YEARS OLD I'M NOT THINK I EARNED
A B. COLUMN IS MARGARET.
I'M ADDS SUBMITTED -- TO POWER
POINTS DID YOU SEE WILL.
I DIDN'T RECEIVE THAT BY THIS
WITH YOU [inaudible]
MARCH.
I RECEIVED YOUR EMAIL BUT I WAS
NOT ABLE TO OF LOCALS POWER
POINT OKAY RIGHT.
WELL ANYWAY FROM THE STAR FROM
OUR ARMED.
ARE BEGINNING AS THE
ORGANIZATION ARE ORGANIZATIONS
CALL WITH LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
INDICATORS PROJECT WE'VE BEEN AT
THIS WORK. FOR TWO DECADES AND I
WORK IS BASED AROUND OF LOOK
ABUSING BE SEARCHING DAY THE AS
A PLATE AS A MARKER FOR ALL
CAMPAIGNS PROJECTS PLANS.
INITIATIVES -- DEVELOPMENT OF
PROJECTS WE WE COME FROM A PLACE
WHERE WE USE A RESEARCH AND
DAVID.
WE ALSO THE FIRST COMMUNITY THAT --
ON THE A. B. SIX ONE SEVEN IS
DOING THE ACTION PLAN WITH THE
ONLY COMMUNITY IN THE STATE IS
DOING THE ACTUAL PLAN WE HAVE
DONE OUR OWN AB ONE THING FOR
THE CLASS.
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS SO WE ARE
VERY FAMILIAR WITH AB MONITORED.
AND SO WHEN YOU START TALK ABOUT
THESE CONTAMINATIONS THAT'S THE
NEW ONE ONE PART OF THE PROBLEMS
THIS HAPPENED TO WES OKLA.
CAM ERICA FOUNDATIONS AIR TALKS
OF POLLUTION THIS ONE PARK WE
HAVE A MULTIPLE PRAWN PROBLEM
WITH WITH -- WITH.
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CRIME AND
JUSTICE IN WEST OAKLAND.
SO IS NOT JUST ONE BANK IS A
MULTIPLE THINGS AND WE CANNOT
THIS CANNOT TALK ABOUT.
AB AIR POLLUTION BASED ON THE
FACT THAT WE LIVE.
WE LIVE IN A A COMMUNITY OF
WHERE THEIR SUPPORT AND THERE'S
EXPANSIONS OF THAT PORT.
THAT HAS IMPACTED WEST OAKLAND
FOR VOTE OVER EIGHTY YEARS THAT
WE AND I'M MORE RECENTLY -- WE
FAMILY AFTER TWENTY YEARS GOT
THE TO THE PLACE WHERE THERE ARE
IN A PLAN OF DOING ZERO EIGHT
MISSIONS.
AFTER TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
OUT SO IT'S NOT JUST ONE THING
IS A MULTIPLE THINGS WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH INFRASTRUCTURE.
ISSUES -- WE HAVE INDOOR AIR
QUALITY ISSUES WE HAVE
TRANSPORTATION ISSUES -- OF OF A
IMPACTS THEM THEN WE ALSO HAVE
TO LOOK AT ENFORCEMENT.
LAND USE PROXIMITY AND EXPOSURE
AND LOCAL REGULATIONS THAT DO
NOT.
SEEM TO MEET UP WITH OUR STATE
REGULATIONS SO IS NOT THIS IS A
MULTIPLE PRONG ISSUE FOR WONDER
COMMUNITY.
ABOUT TWENTY ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND PEOPLE BECAUSE WE HAVE
A MULTIPLE LEVELS OF IMPACTS.
SO IS THIS NOT THE POLLUTION
ISSUE WAS NOT LIKELY AT AIR
TOXIC CONTAMINATION IS ALSO THAT
LIKE A STATE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
EXPOSURE IS LAND USE.
AND OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVEN'T
A MULTI PLANT MOST WILL PROMPT
PLANT UP ENGAGEMENT OF COMMUNITY
ENGAGEMENT SO THE COMMUNITY HAVE
A BOWEL.
EIGHT VALUE ROLE IN DEVELOPING
THE OWN THEIR OWN STRATEGIES
THAT BASICALLY THAT WE SEE AS A
COMMUNITY THAT WILL BENEFIT US.
AT NOT JUST COLD BEEN APPROVED
BUT THE BENEFITS BUT NOT THE
HELP HARM.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO JUST SAY THAT
WE HAVE THE ISSUE OF JUST.
LOOKING AT POLLUTION AND
CONTAMINATION IS JUST ONE PART
OF A PUZZLE THAT SUPPORT THAT
THIS ONE COMMUNITY NEEDS.
I HAVE AND HAVE BEEN ONGOING FOR
OVER.
IN MY TIME I'VE BEEN AS AS AS A
CITY WIDE IF.
THEY HAVE WHAT YOU CALL THE
CLIMATE ACTION PLAN.
AND NOW HIS CHANGES TO FROM --
FROM THAT ENERGY ACTION PLAY OF
THE WEAPON IN THE PLAN IN HIS
ACTUAL PLAN THEY HAVE TO IT
WOULD BE ACTUAL PLAN.
SO WE DON'T HAVE WHAT WE HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO HAVE THESE REAL
ROLE BUS.
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING THAT WAS
SUPPORT ALL THE COULDN'T THOSE
COMMUNITIES.
THAT GOES DOWN. EIGHT EIGHT A
QUARTER THERE ARE IMPACTED FROM
ALL THESE DIFFERENT.
THINGS THAT I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
SO WHAT WE WOULD.
WE DO NEED AS WE CAN YOU.
THE USING THE POWER.
UP SB. SIX ONE SEVEN TO REALLY
TRULY PUT THE COMMUNITY.
AT A PLACE WHERE WE ARE AND THE
ASSISTANT IN LEARNING ABOUT THE
SCIENCE THE MONITORING AND PLAN
AND HOW DO WE RATE
TRANSPORTATION PLANS.
TRANSPORTATION.
PLANS AND OUT OF WORK WHO ARE
ERE DISTRICT TO BE -- WORKING IN
COLLABORATION AND USING
COMMUNITY A COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT
UP.
PROCESSES TO BE MORE INCLUDING.
OF US AS A VALUE AND NOT JUST AS
THE AS A DETRIMENT BUT AS A BAG --
TO BE ABLE TO TO TO UP
[inaudible] TO FULFILL THOSE
OBLIGATIONS WILL HELP THE
COMMUNITY THEN WE ALSO OUR
COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE
UNDERSTANDING -- WORKING WITH
THOSE PART OF THOSE STAKEHOLDERS
THAT WILL TRULY WANTS TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP.
AND WOOD TECHNICAL PUT CAPACITY
AND THE NEEDS FOR WORKING WITH A
WOULD COMMUNITY AND TRAINING.
ONE OF THINGS WE FOUND OUT EVERY
AGENCY STAFF PERSON SHOULD NOT
BE IN A ROOM WITH COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SKILLS THAT.
THEY DON'T KNOW THE LANGUAGE
DON'T KNOW THE COMMUNITY THEY
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING OUT OF OUT
OF IN A VACUUM SOMEWHERE IN TWO
EIGHT TWO WILL GO ARE INTO A
DEBTS ARE OUT OF A BOOK.
THAT HAVE THEY'VE NEVER HAD A
REAL ENGAGEMENT WITH WITH THOSE
WHO ARE BIMBOS WOMBLE THEY DON'T
KNOW THE LANGUAGE THEY DON'T
KNOW THE PEOPLE AND SOMEONE
WOULD JUST PLAYING OUT JUST A
YEAR.
ALL RIGHT SO AND THEN THE LAST
THING WE NEED LONG TERM
FINANCING TO SUPPORT.
IT.
OUR NEW AIRPLANES OVER TIME.
SO WITH THE THE BOTH WILL PROMPT
PLANNING NOT JUST TO DEAL WITH
THIS CONTAMINATION WE NEED A
MUCH MORE.
THE PUZZLES ALL THESE PIECES
TOGETHER BUT THIS PUZZLE BECAUSE
THIS LONG TERM THING I'M NOT NOT
BE ABLE TO WIN BUT TWENTY FIFTY
ALL RIGHT AB.
SEVENTY TWO ABOUT LET ABOUT DID
HE THE S. NEXT THIRTY ONE YEARS
AS A HUNDRED YEARS OLD I HAD THE
GOOD.
SO ANYWAY BUT DOESN'T SAY THAT
WE NEED JUST MORE MUCH MORE THAN
JUST TALK ABOUT CONTAMINATION WE
GOT TO TALK ABOUT THE WHOLE BIG
PICTURE WE GOT BIG PICTURE.
ISSUE WE GOT HAVE A BIG PICTURE
IDEAS BIG PICTURE PLANNING BIG.
IT'S A FINANCING TO DEAL WITH
LL THESE ISSUES AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS MARGRET -- YOU
TALK ABOUT NEEDING ROBUST
COMPREHENSIVE PLANNING AND HOW
IT HASN'T BEEN HAPPENING.
WHAT ARE SOME OF THE IDEAS YOU
THINK THAT WE NEED TO ADOPT TO
HELP?
THAT HAPPEN IN A WAY THAT --
SETTLEMENT SAYING I WILL SAY
THIS AT THE BAR I WAS A
SEVENTEEN YEAR IT UP AND GET UP --
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THE AIR DISTRICT FROM THE BAY
AREA.
SO I HAVE SO.
WE HAVE SHAPED A LOT OF THAT
STAFF.
WHEN THEY WANT TO COME TO THE TO
WEST OAKLAND THEY KNOW WHAT TO
EXPECT AND HAVE A?
AND WE HAVE CERTAIN EXPECTATIONS
OF THE SO THAT'S HOW WE WERE
ABLE TO DO OUR PARTNERSHIP.
BOB HOPE PARTNERSHIP WITH THEM
IN.
AND DEVELOPING THIS SB SIX UP SB
SIX ACTUALLY PLAYED.
EVERYBODY A IN HAD THE BILL HAVE
THE SAME TYPE OF LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEIR OF
THEIR DISTRICTS THAT'S NUMBER.
ONE AND ALSO WE HAVE HAD WE HAVE
HEAD RELATIONSHIPS THE BUILDING
ALL OF THE PROJECTS THAT DEALING
WITH THE CITY A WITH THE WITH
THE PORT OF OAKLAND.
ARE THE CITY OAKLAND PORTAL
OPENED SO WE HAVE HAD WE HAVE
HAD DIFFERENT TYPES OF
ENGAGEMENT SO WE AT SOME
FUNDAMENTAL UNDERSTANDING OF
EACH OTHER'S.
EACH OTHER BUT BUT SOME STEP.
I BIGGEST MY BIGGEST PROBLEM IN
SCIENCE THAT IS DEALING WITH IT.
STAFF IS THAT THE CITY OF
OAKLAND AND START MAYOR STAFF
AVAILABLE CAR.
THEY HAVE THEY BEEN IN THE Q.
WILL GO AND ALL THOSE THAT HAVE
NO TRAINING UNDERSTAND TO BE
ENGAGING.
WITH COMMUNITY.
THEY HAD NO TRAINING THEY HAVE
NO SKILL SET NO PROBLEM.
ALL RIGHT THEY DID STE I DON'T
KNOW WITH SOMEONE COME FROM I
DON'T KNOW THE EXPANSIVE I HAVE
NO REAL BOTTLES ONLY UP I JUST
DON'T WE JUST DON'T KNOW AND
THEY COME WITH.
WITH.
BANGS THAT DEATH I'M NOT A
PROBLEM FARM WITH JUSTICE I
DON'T KNOW IS FROM A BUSINESS
PLAN I DON'T KNOW WHERE IT COME
FROM IS A TOLD THE BUREAUCRACY.
A WHAT SOME FOLKS NEED TO BE
TRYING TO REPORT TO COME OUT AND
TO COMMUNITY I'M JUST SORRY BIG
JUST.
NEED THAT SKILL SET.
AND THEN I'M ALSO GOING TO SAY
THAT WHEN IT COMES OUT TO
STRUCTURAL PROJECTS UP AS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
NEEDS FOR OUR COMMUNITY OUR OUR
WE NEED TO BE ABLE.
TO TALK ABOUT.
WHAT WE KNOW THAT HAS BEEN THE
PROBLEM NOT SUB?
ENGINEER COMING INTELLIGENCE
WHAT THEY KNOW WAS THE PROBLEM
NO THEY NEED TO LISTEN TO WHAT
WE DIDN'T KNOW HOW OFTEN.
THIS CORNER RIGHT HERE FROM THE
FROM OF FROM RAIN ARE FROM THE
ARE ARE HOW OFTEN WE HAVE WHEN
WE HAVE A A A HI
IT'S WHERE THEIR DAYS THAT WE
HAVE TO CLOSE OUT WINDOWS AND
NOT A NO -- HAVE SPARE THEIR
DAYS BUT WE KNOW THAT WE DON'T
HAVE WE HAVE TO RUN A PAIN TO BE
ABLE TO COOL OFF THE COMMUNE OUR
OUR HOUSES.
ARE WHICH COMMUNITIES THOSE NEED
TO BE.
RE ASSESSED TO BE ABLE TO DEAL
WITH AS A COOL CONSUMER WE NEED
PEOPLE JUST TO LISTEN TO
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE COME FROM.
AND THEN LET'S MOVE THIS.
BILL WHERE HOW WE WILL BE
COMPATIBLE WITH EACH OTHER WHAT
WE THOUGHT WE SEE ARE THE THINGS
THAT WE CAN -- WE CAN
COLLABORATE ABOUT AND THEN I'D
ALSO BE A WHIP.
PUT TO THE PARKING LOT WHERE WE
THINK THAT WE NEED TO DEBATE.
I WE HAVE COMPLEX ABOUT AND
BLANK IF NECESSARY FRONT IN A
FACILITATOR OF CONFLICT
RESOLUTION PERSON TO SUPPORT OF
TO GET BEYOND THAT.
SO THIS IS THE KIND OF THING IS
ACTUALLY IS.
NEEDED FOR US TO HAVE A VERY
COMPREHENSIVE ROBUST.
PLANNING FOR OUR COMMUNITY OF
HIS MOBILE THIS BIG PICTURE.
MISS MARGARET -- A I AGREE WITH
YOU.
I HEAR THIS BACK HOME I HAVE A A
MORE SPECIFIC QUESTION --
RECENTLY BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH TO DO I DECIDED TO DELVE
INTO.
THESE PUBLIC DATA SET THAT WE
HAVE ONLINE I WHETHER IT'S TO DO
OUR CALAVERAS WIENER OR THROUGH.
DIFFERENT DATA SETS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO OUR WATER BOARDS
AND OUR LOCAL ARE DISTRICTS --
AND SOMEWHERE A LITTLE
FRIENDLIER THAN OTHERS -- FOR
FROM MYSELF ALONG THE WAY.
WHEN?
YOU'VE BEEN THERE FOR FOR A LONG
TIME AND BUILDING THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS ARE WORKING ON
COMMUNITY ACTION PLANS.
HOW USEFUL HAS THE STATE OF AN
OUT THERE ON GHG INVENTORIES ARE
OR ANYTHING ELSE IN IN THE WORK
THAT YOU'RE DOING IT IS THIS
THIS THIS HELP IS NOT?
IS NOT A POPULAR EDUCATION
FORMAT.
IT DOES NOT GET TO THE HEART OF
WHAT PEOPLE WHERE PEOPLE ARE.
SOMEBODY WENT INTO A ROOM
SOMEWHERE AND THE THAT.
THAT WAS NO EXCHANGE OF IDEAS
OUR EXPERIENCES WIND THAT WAS
DEVELOPED.
WE ALSO WENT DEVELOPING TO SAY
WHAT HERE THIS IS IT.
AND AND AND AND AND DIDN'T EVEN
INCLUDE THE HISTORICAL -- OF
THEY HISTORICAL -- EXPERIENCES
WHAT A WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO SOME
COMMUNITIES IN SOME OF THESE.
SOME OF THESE WEBSITES.
SO IT.
EVERY EVERY THERE'S NOT ONE SIZE
FITS ALL.
AND IT'S CLEARLY THAT.
THE SCIENCES BY THE TIME OF THE
TAKE THE PERSON DID NOT CLEARLY
DID NOT UNDERSTANDING
[inaudible]
THAT.
THE NEW THERE'S A NEW WAY OF
SEEING.
HOW COMMUNITIES SEES ITSELF
BASED ON HIS OWN?
NEEDS.
AND DESIRES AND HEALTH IT'S NOT
ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
SO THAT'S IT THANKS.
SOME OF THOSE.
MYSELF PERSONALLY AS A CO
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZATION ALWAYS
HAVE.
LEARN TO FIND OUT.
BY MY OWN TECHNICAL PERSON THANK
YOU BREAK IT DOWN. TO THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITY.
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE OUR
OWN TECHNICAL PEOPLE TO BE OUR
TECHNICAL PEOPLE THE SCIENTISTS
THE ENGINEER WHOEVER THE IS WE
NEED TO HAVE BE ABLE. TO SELECT
OUR OWN PEOPLE OP I'M I'M NOT
DEPEND ON OWN.
OF THE OF THE AGENCIES.
DOCUMENTATION WHAT OUT HAVE BEEN
SOMEBODY ELSE [inaudible]
DO A TRYING TO REFINE IT TO THE
PLACE WHERE I CAN I CAN GO BACK
AND TALK TO MY NEIGHBORS ABOUT.
I COULD GO BACK TALK TO MY
GRANDCHILDREN ABOUT.
AND I FEEL THAT SOME OF THE
STUFF DOES DOES NOT RELATE.
DOES NOT HELP TO EMPOWER THE
COMMUNITY BY HAVING THE ABILITY
BE ORIENTATED THE EDUCATE. TO BE
ABLE TO MAKE THOSE PLANS BE
ENGAGING IN THE PLANNING PROCESS.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS YOU SPOKE
ABOUT IS HEALTH METRICS THE DATA
OUT THERE DOESN'T GIVE US THAT
CONNECTION NO.
NO ARE THERE OTHER CONNECTIONS
BEYOND HELP THAT YOU THINK ARE
IMPORTANT AS WERE LOOKING AT
THIS DATA TO MAKE IT MORE USEFUL
RELATABLE.
I THINK ALSO THE DISTANT LOOK
THESE COMMUNITY.
MANY OF THESE COMMUNICATION
DEPARTMENT'S.
DO NOT KNOW HOW TO MESSAGE TO
COMMUNITY -- SPECIALLY THOSE
IMPACTED INVIOLABLE COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO
ASK THE QUESTION.
THEY DO MAKE A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS.
AND I THINK THAT.
HAVE A LOT OF SUBSTANCE.
AT ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT COMMUNITY
AT BUT IS THIS DOES DOES I'M NOT
RACES.
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE YOU USUALLY
BE RELAXED ENOUGH BINGO AND A
JOB.
AND TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN WHERE
IS THAT THE COMMUNITY SHOULD BE
AT THE CENTER PLACE OF SHAPING.
MESSAGING [inaudible]
MR RUSSELL.
I'M SURE JUST WANTED A THANK.
MISS GORDON FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
I'VE I'VE BEEN IN THIS
LEGISLATURE FOR QUITE AWHILE NOW
I MY NINETY YEAR AND I SERVED AT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AS A COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR FIVE YEARS AND PRIOR
TO THAT.
I ACTUALLY WORK FOR THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO AS A PROJECT MANAGER
ONE OF THE UC DEPARTMENTS THAT
HANDLED COMMUTING ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND I'VE HAD A THE
CHANCE TO WORK -- FACING WITH
COMMUNITIES OF DIFFERENT LEVELS
BEGINNING.
AS AN ADVOCATE FOR MY OWN
COMMUNITY.
AND IT'S A IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
THING FOR YOU TO FIGHT FOR YOUR
COMMUNITY AND AND SAY THIS IS
WHAT I WANT GOVERNMENT TO DO
WELL FOR US AND IT'S A DIFFERENT
PLACE TO BE WHERE WE ARE SO.
I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME LET ME TELL YOU YOUR YOUR
MESSAGE HERE TODAY'S VERY
REFRESHING THAT SOMETHING VERY
DIFFERENT AND SOMETHING I NEVER
HEARD.
FROM SOMEBODY IN THE COMMUNITY
SAY THAT.
WE NEED TO NEED TO FIND BETTER
WAYS STE.
WAYS TO HAVE.
THE GOVERNMENT WORK FOR OUR
COMMUNITY IN THAT AT ALL IN A
AND A CAPACITY WERE WERE
ACTUALLY.
NOT ONLY LISTENING BUT PUT IN.
OUR CONSTITUENTS IN THE DRIVER
SEAT.
WHEN YOU SAY THAT WE WE NEED
ENGINEERS AND WE NEED SEAT NEED
SCIENTISTS YOU ACTUALLY HAVE
THEM?
AND THEY THEY WORK FOR YOU.
AND THEY SHOULD BE WORKING TO
SOLVE PROBLEMS ON YOUR BEHALF
AND MAKING SURE THAT YOUR YOUR
HEARD AND ONE OF THINGS SAID
THAT.
THAT FRUSTRATED ME MORE AS A
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE IS ACTUALLY
MAKE YOU PUTTING IN PHONE CALLS
TO LEADERS AND CHOOSE A
COMMUNITY -- TO CITY STAFFORD
COUNTY STAFF AND NEVER GET TO
GET MY CALL RETURN.
IT'S A HORRIBLE FEELING TO PUT
IN A CALL AND HAVE IT BE IGNORED.
MAKES YOU FEEL LIKE.
YOU'RE NOBODY MAKES YOU FEEL
THIS BIG.
WHEN I PROMISE NEVER TO DO THAT?
BUT AT THE SAME TIME I'VE BEEN
ON THE ON THE ON THIS SIDE
TRYING TO REACH OUT TO MY
COMMUNITY GET PEOPLE ENGAGE AND
TRY TO GET THEM TRYING TO GET
THEM. TO LEAD ON CERTAIN ISSUES
HAVING MIXED RESULTS IN SOME
CASES WE HAD ENORMOUS SUCCESS
AND OTHERS -- PEOPLE ARE LESS
SEEMED SEEM TO BE LESS
INTERESTED OR NOT GONNA BLAME IT
ON THEM.
BECAUSE FINDING THE RIGHT
STRATEGIES OUT REACH IS ALWAYS A
CHALLENGE.
IT'S ALWAYS VERY DIFFICULT
HAVING PEOPLE THAT ARE PRO
ACTIVELY ENGAGED AND KNOCKING ON
DOORS IS IS NOT ALWAYS.
COMMON PLACE IN EVERY COMMUNITY.
ESPECIALLY IN THE MOST
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WHERE PEOPLE TEND TO FEEL MORE
FRUSTRATED AND FEEL LIKE THEIR
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T WORK FOR THEM?
NOT KNOWING THAT THEY CAN
HARNESS THE POWER OF GOVERNMENT
TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
SO.
YOU KNOW I I RECEIVE YOUR
MESSAGE AS A CHALLENGE HERE FOR
US. TO TO LOOK AT THIS ISSUE AND
SAY HOW DO WE DO A BETTER JOB
CONNECTING.
WITH OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE THEY
CAN TEACH US SO MUCH.
ABOUT HOW TO BETTER PLAN WE
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO WAIT FOR A
CONFLICT TO ARISE. TO RESPOND TO
A NEED.
AND IN MY EXPERIENCE IF THE WE
HAD AN AIR QUALITY PROBLEM BLOT
BROUGHT ON BY A CHROMIUM PLATING
BUSINESS.
THE JUST SIMPLY WAS [inaudible]
OPERATING [inaudible]
WANTONLY OR IT A IN IN IN
[inaudible]
IN.
NOT IN RESPECT OF OF OUR LAWS
AND OUR C<c.cyan> AIR QUALITY LAWS</c>
WHAT WE DID IS WE HAD TO RISE UP.
AND AND AND CREATE A CONFLICT TO
GET PEOPLE IN GOVERNMENT TO
LISTEN TO US IN A XIN HAVE HAVE
TO COME TO THAT.
SHOULD NOT HAVE TO COME FOR TO
US SAYING.
COME LISTEN TO US.
THE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT STATE
GOVERNMENT ALL GOVERNMENT HAS TO
INVEST IN NOT REACHING HAS TO
INVEST IN CONNECTING WITH THE
PUBLIC AND HAS.
TO START WORKING ON ADDRESSING
THOSE SCHOOLS PROACTIVELY BEFORE.
SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS BEFORE.
OF PEOPLE NOW HAVE COMMUNITY
HAVE TO ORGANIZE RUN ISSUE
BECAUSE THEY'RE FRUSTRATED NO.
AND AND JUST FEEL COMPLETELY
IGNORED SO.
I'M TELLING YOU I'VE NEVER.
AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN HERE I'VE
AND HURT SOMEBODY LIKE YOU COME
FORWARD AND AND MAKE THESE
COMMENTS IN THE MANNER THAT YOU
HAVE AN AND I APPRECIATE YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALL THAT YOU'VE
DONE AND AND THAT YOU ARE --
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THIS MESSAGE JUST WANT TO THANK
YOU.
AND I LIKE THE ONES ARE ALSO A
AS OUR ORGANIZATION WE DEVELOP.
A PLAN TO GET OUR OWN TECHNICAL
RESOURCES SO WE HAVE OUR OWN
EHRMANN BRING WOMEN.
TRYING TO COMMUNITY RESIDENTS
HOW TO USETHAT EQUIPMENT WE
TAKE THAT WE HAVE TAKEN A QUICK
APPOINTMENT UP AND DOWN THE
STATE CROSS AND THEY SHOULD.
SHOW OF THE COMMUNITIES HOW.
THEY CAN IMPROVE THEIR OWN
ISSUES GET THE EVIDENCE.
AND I'M LIKE I SAID BEFORE WE
HAVE OUR OWN RESEARCH TEAM AND
PARTNERSHIP WITH.
BOSE.
THOSE OF THOSE MOST TECHNICAL WE
DO I DO NOT GO INTO A ANYTHING
WHAT HAPPENED A REAL STRATEGY
UNDERSTANDING ROLES AND TASKS
[inaudible]
FUNDING TOOLS ALL THOSE THINGS
AND PART OF THE ISSUES THAT MOST
OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND LOT OF I
MEAN THE ORGANIZATIONS.
MAKING REMAINS AND THAT COME
WITH THE EVIDENCE WE NEED TO
COME OUT OWN EVIDENCE TO PROVE
OUR ISSUE.
NOT MAKING DEMANDS AND YOU DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO SHOW THAT THIS
IS THE ISSUE.
SO THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE HOW HOW
DO YOU WORK IN COLDEST WHAT
WORKING COALITION WORK IN
COLLABORATION.
AND HAVING THOSE TECHNICAL
THINGS IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
ALL OUR COMMUNITIES DO NOT HAVE
THAT CAPACITY AND THAT'S ONE OF
THE KEY ISSUE.
BACK KEY COMMUNITIES FROM NOT
BEING ABLE TO ENGAGE AS ROBUSTLY
AND HAPPEN COMPREHENSIVE BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THAT CAPACITY.
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT.
THESE LAST YEAR'S OF MIND THAT I
AM PUTTING FORTH HOW DO I GIVE
BACK TO THOSE COMMUNITIES TO
LEARN HOW TO USE THESE.
THESE TOOLS AND RESOURCES THAT I
LEARNED OVER THE LAST THIRTY
YEARS.
SO ARE NOT ALL COMMUNITIES HAVE
A A MISS MARGARET WE'RE NOT ALL
AS THIS LUCKY DO YOU HAVE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF HOW WE HEAR
CAN HELP [inaudible]
HELP.
DEVELOP THAT EXPERTISE HELPED
CREATE MORE MISS MARKETS OTHER
HELP YOU AT YOUR WORK AS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SHARING YOUR
SCHOOL SITTING IN FOR EXPERTISE
WITH OTHER COMMUNITIES.
HOW DO WE HELP THAT SO THAT WE
CAN GET FASTER AND DEEPER AS
THIS NICKEL SAID EARLIER AND I
ADVOCACY WORK OKAY BUT?
A LITTLE ONE THE THINGS IS THAT
THAT THAT HAS TO HAPPEN IS THAT.
AYE AYE AS ONE INDIVIDUAL NEED
TO BE IN A PLACE WHERE IS THAT I
CAN MEET.
COMMUNITY WHERE THEY'RE AT AND
WORK WITH THEM WHERE THEY'RE AT
TO GO TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
KEEP GOING TO THE NEXT LEVEL.
IF I DON'T HAVE A BOTTLE HAVE
THE THE RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT MY
MYSELF AND MY FAMILY TO BE BUT
THIS WILL HELP SUPPORT OTHER
PEOPLE.
I'M COSTS THE EITHER ON EMAIL
I'M DOING IT BY EMAIL AS SOON AS
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
OUR PAINT THINGS ON MY OWN
POCKET TO GET TO SOME PLACE.
SO I REALLY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE
SOMEPLACE WHERE THIS ANNUAL.
ANNUAL SETTINGS WHERE I COULD
COME ARE.
BY BUT LEAVE SAVINGS WHAT I
COULD COME AND WORK WITH THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO REQUESTS.
MIKE TYPE OF ENGAGEMENT.
I I'M I'M NOT A PERSON TO PUT
JUST.
PUT MYSELF ON YOU BUT IF I CAN
GET TO THE PLACE WHERE THAT YOU
REALLY WANT TO KNOW OUT OUT OUT
OF A BRAIN DUMP ALL DAY LONG.
WHICH IS WHAT I HAVE DONE AND
HAVE AND HAVE DONE TO BUILDINGS
RELATIONSHIPS BECAUSE IT'S STILL
COMES DOWN TO BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS.
GOOD BAD INDIFFERENT YOU KNOW
WHEN EVERYTHING WHICH IS STILL
GOT TO KEEP THIS WOULD GET TO
KEEP THAT.
THAT PATHWAY OF RELATIONSHIPS
OPEN [inaudible]
WITH [inaudible]
THE POLLUTERS [inaudible]
WITH REGULATORS.
WITH THAT TAKE THE PEOPLE YOU
DON'T LIKE.
YOU STILL GOT TO KEEP THE WITH
EVEN TODAY YOU HAVE BELIEVE WE
GOT TO GO BUT TOMORROW I'LL CALL
YOU LATER.
BUT YOU HAVE TO KEEP THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS OPEN.
AND I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS IS NOT ABOUT THEM WITH
THOSE GUYS WITH AIR QUALITY DOES
NOT HAVE.
DOES NOT SEEM THE EVERYBODY'S
LOANS THE SAME WAY I WILL GET
YOU.
WELL WITH THAT THANK YOU MISS
MARKET I DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR TIME AND YOUR WITH THEM --
YOU GAVE ME SOME HOMEWORK OF HOW
DO I MAKE SURE I HOPE YOU GET
OUT THERE ALL RIGHT I I HEARD
YOU AND I DO WANT YOU OUT THERE
SO.
MAYBE IT'S SOMETHING THAT THE
AIRPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
FUNDING WE COULD TALK ABOUT HOW
TO MAKE THAT MORE FEASIBLE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
MISS MARGARET.
AND FINALLY I HAVE.
COMING UP HERE.
MICHAEL CLARA BORN WHO IS.
WITH THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY HE'S
GOING TO BE TALKING TO US A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT.
THE URBAN IN THIS A SIDE OF
THINGS ASK I WANTED TO MAKE SURE
WE HAD UR PRESENTATION ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND THAT I REMEMBER THAT IT'S
NOT JUST ABOUT MY BACKYARD BUT
ABOUT THE FORTY MILLION ANGELINO
SOUTH INCLUDING OUR FOLKS AND
THE AG INDUSTRY.
AND SO MICHAEL THANK YOU FOR
MAKING TIME FOR US TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR
AND TO THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME'S ABOUT CLAIBORNE I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY --
WHERE AN ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
NONPROFIT BASED AND FRESNO WITH
OFFICES IN BAKERSFIELD AND THESE
COACHELLA VALLEY?
AND THE CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE EFFORTS AND ROLLER
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES REQUIRE
LOCAL COMMUNITY LEVEL PLANNING.
AND SMART INVESTMENTS THAT MAKES
SENSE UNDER THE SPECIFIC
CIRCUMSTANCES FACING EACH
COMMUNITY.
CLIMATE CHANGE PLANNING AND
INVESTMENTS IN ADDITION TO BEING
NECESSARY TO FACE AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT.
PRESENT AN OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN
TO ADDRESS HISTORIC INEQUITIES
AND LACK OF INVESTMENT IN
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
THE S. COACHELLA VALLEY AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE REQUIRES IMPROVED
COORDINATION BETWEEN STATE
AGENCIES.
AND ALIGNMENT OF STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS TO MEANINGFULLY RESPOND.
TO CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
FACING FRONT LINE COMMUNITIES.
THESE THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY IF WE'RE GOING TO MEET
OUR SB THIRTY TWO GOALS.
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY IS HOME.
TO MANY INDUSTRIAL FACILITIES IN
THE MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S
INDUSTRIALIZED FACTORY FARMS
INCLUDING DERRY'S AS WELL AS 30%
OF THE MOST ENVIRONMENTALLY
IMPACTED COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA --
ACCORDING CALAMARI SCREEN
SOLUTIONS MUST MEANINGFULLY
ADDRESS AGRICULTURAL AND AT AN
INDUSTRIAL EMISSIONS AND RURAL
AREAS LIKE IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
I'M GONNA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT TO COMMUNITIES THAT I WORK
WITH -- ALONG SIDE AND REPRESENT
AND THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY --
THE FIRST COMMUNITY IT'S CALLED
TO REBEL IT'S AN TO LARRY COUNTY
IT'S A COMMUNITY OF SEVENTY SIX
HOMES.
JUST.
ABOUT A MILE EAST OF EXETER AND
IT SITS AT THE BASE OF THE
FOOTHILLS -- IN THE CENTRAL
SIERRA NEVADA MOUNTAINS AND
IMMEDIATELY ADJACENT AT ACTUALLY
AT THE END OF THE STREETS TO THE
FRANK CURRENT CAN NOW.
IT'S A LOW INCOME COMMUNITY
WITHIN AN ESTIMATED MHI OF ABOUT
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
PER YEAR.
AND THE COMMUNITY HAS STRUGGLED
WITH DRINKING WATER QUALITY AND
QUANTITY ISSUES FOR DECADES --
INCLUDING CONTAMINATION FROM
NITRATE HEXAVALENT CHROMIUM --
AND MOST RECENTLY SALINITY WHICH
HAS CAUSED PROBLEMS WITH A FEW
THINGS I'LL GET -- TO GIVEN
PROXIMITY TO THE SIERRA
FOOTHILLS WHICH OBVIOUSLY GIVE
VERY DRY IN THE SUMMER -- THERE
IS EXTREME VIRUS SCAN IN THE
COMMUNITY OF TO REBEL AND VERY
LOW FIRE FLOW SO WHEN YOU FOR
TALKING ABOUT FIRE PROTECTION.
THE FIRE FLOW JUST ISN'T THERE
FOR THAT.
I INTENTIONALLY HIGH
TEMPERATURES IN THE CM A SUMMER
AND TO THE BILL SOMETIMES EXCEED
OFTEN EXCEED.
A HUNDRED AND TEN DEGREES -- ANA
WITH AN AVERAGE OF BEFORE
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR OF THESE
HIGH HEAT DAYS PER YEAR BUT
CALIDAD.
PREDICTS THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
MORE LIKE FORTY SIX TO EIGHTY
HIGH HEAT THE DAYS AND TO A BILL.
BY TWENTY SEVENTY SO THE PROBLEM
IS GOING TO GET A WHOLE LOT
WORSE.
MOST RESIDENTS DO NOT HAVE AIR
CONDITIONING INTO REBEL AND
INSTEAD RELY ON SWAMP COOLERS --
ANYBODY THAT USED A SWAMP COOLER
KNOWS THAT THAT START GETTING
LESS AND LESS EFFECTIVE AS THAT
TEMPERATURE RISES.
AND EDITION OF THAT PROBLEM --
INTO REBEL THE SALINITY IN THE
WATER IS CLOGGING UP THOSE SMALL
COOLER SO THEY DON'T EVEN
FUNCTION AS WELL AS THEY
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE --
ADDITIONALLY. TWO WE WILL AS
EXCEEDED STATE AND WHAT THE
SALINITY ISSUE -- AND THEN THE
LOW PRESSURE ISSUE ALSO IMPACTS
THE SWAMP COOLERS IN A WAY THAT
MAKES IT NOT FUNCTION VERY WELL.
THE COMMUNITY ALSO HAS TO DEAL
WITH HIGH AGRICULTURAL EMISSIONS
FROM NEARBY ORANGE ORCHARDS AND
THOSE INCLUDE AND AS WE KNOW PM
TWO POINT FIVE PM TEN PESTICIDES
AND NOT TRUE NATURES OXIDE.
PESTICIDE PROBLEMS OF GOT MORE
SEVERE AS HIGH HEAT DAYS AND
WARM NIGHTS HAVE BECOME MORE
COMMON.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT AND I
COMMUNITY AND IN MANY
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY TO LEAVE WINDOWS OPEN AT
NIGHT BECAUSE OF POOR AIR
QUALITY.
IT'S ALSO DIFFICULT FOR FOLKS.
TO KEEP THEIR SWAMP COOLERS AND
IF THEY'RE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
AIR CONDITIONING.
RUNNING AT NIGHT FOR THE SAME
REASONS -- TO REVEAL IS
APPROXIMATELY LIKE I SAID A MILE
FROM THE CITY OF EXETER AND THAT
MEANS THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
DISTANCE BETWEEN TWO REBEL ANNEX
THERE THAT THE COOLING CENTERS
IN EXETER.
ARE -- IMPRACTICAL TO ACCESS FOR
FOLKS WITHOUT CARS AND THAT'S
MANY IN THE COMMUNITY.
SO THERE'S ALSO TRANSPORTATION
ASPECT TO THIS.
MOST OF THESE ISSUES ARE NOT
READILY APPARENT JUST FROM
LOOKING AT STATE DATA SOURCES
LIKE CALLUM IRIS SCREEN. FOR
EXAMPLE CALAVERAS DURING --
SHOWS TO LEGALIZE WITHIN A
CENSUS TRACT THAT STOP FORTIETH
PERCENTILE -- IT'S LUMPED IN
WITH A BIG PORTION OF THIS YEAR
AS AND IT DOESN'T CAPTURE A
COMMUNITY AS SMALL AS TO EGO --
SO STATE LEVEL POLLS LIKE
CALABAR FIRE SCREEN WHILE
PROVIDING VERY CRITICAL
INFORMATION OR LOOKING AT THESE
PROBLEMS ON A SENSE OF SCALE
OFTEN OVERLOOKED COMMUNITIES
LIKE TO THE BILL.
DUE TO THEIR SMALL SIZE COMPARED
AT SUCH A SIZE OF THE CENSUS
TRACT -- TO LEGAL THAT'S
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR LOCAL
PLANNING AND MEANINGFUL
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT TO ENSURE
THAT CLIMATE ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCY EFFORTS.
ARE TAILORED TO SPECIFIC
COMMUNITIES AND ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THE ISSUES ON THE GROUND IN
THOSE COMMUNITIES.
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO EVEN
IDENTIFY WHAT THE PROBLEMS ARE
LITTLE ON SOLVE THOSE PROBLEMS
AT AND LESS WE ACTUALLY GO TO
COMMUNITIES.
MEETING FULLY ENGAGE RESIDENTS
AND IDENTIFY SOLUTIONS BASED ON
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ON THE GROUND.
A SIMILAR SET OF CIRCUMSTANCES
IS PROVIDED BY THE COMMUNITIES
OF CAN'T TO A CREE CANNOT
PORTMAN HERE.
IN WESTERN FRESNO COUNTY BOTH
COMMUNITY IS OUR IMMEDIATELY
ADJACENT AND ABOUT AN HOUR -- TO
THE WEST OF THE CITY OF FRESNO.
BOTH ARE A LITTLE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
AND BOTH HAVE STRUGGLED WITH
POOR WATER QUALITY.
AIR QUALITY AND LACK OF
EFFECTIVE TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
IN TERMS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
IMPACTS RESIDENTS OF CAN'T TO A
CREEK AND EL PORVENIR STRUGGLE
WHICH RANKING WATER THAT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN CONTAMINATED
BUT WITH NITRATE.
AND MORE RECENTLY WITH SOMETHING
CALLED DISINFECTANT BY PRODUCTS
WHICH IS A RESULT OF RECEIVING
WATER FROM WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT THAT TO BE TREATED --
AND PROVIDED AND PRODUCED
DISINFECTANT BRIGHT BY PRODUCTS
SUCH THAT THE WATER CAN'T BE --
CONSUMED OR SHOULDN'T BE
CONSUMED.
AND BASED ON THIS ARRANGEMENT
WITH WESTLANDS FOLKS ARE ALSO --
EXPERIENCING VERY VERY HIGH
WATER BILLS -- SOMETIMES OVER A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR
WATER THAT RESIDENTS CAN'T DRINK.
LIKE TO LEGAL RESIDENTS
EXPERIENCE HIGH HE DAIS AND MANY
RESIDENTS LACK AIR CONDITIONING
AND COULDN'T AFFORD TO RUN A
CONDITIONING IF THAT HAD IT.
THESE ISSUES ARE EXACERBATED BY
ISSUES WITH THEIR WATER SYSTEM --
LIKE INTO A BILL.
GIVEN THE LONG ONE HOUR DRIVE TO
FRESNO FOR ESSENTIAL SERVICES
LIKE MEDICAL APPOINTMENTS ACCESS
TO GROCERY STORES AND LEGAL
SERVICES.
ALONG WITH THE FACT THAT MANY
RESIDENTS LACKED VEHICLES AND
CAN AFFORD CANNOT AFFORD GAS FOR
FREQUENT TRIPS TO FRESNO.
RESIDENTS IDENTIFIED
IMPROVEMENTS TO TRANSPORTATION
AS HIGH PRIORITY. FOR THE BOTH
COMMUNITIES TO RESPOND TO THE
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS
COMMUNITY RESIDENTS PARTNERED
WITH.
MY ORGANIZATION AND A RIDE CHER
COMPANY CALLED GREEN COMMUTER
AND ORGAN OTHER ORGANIZATIONS TO
START THE COUNTRY'S FIRST ALL
ELECTRIC RURAL RIDE CHER.
THEY NOW HAVE TO ELECTRIC
VEHICLES THAT ARE DRIVEN BY
RESIDENTS -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE RESIDENTS ABOUT COMMUNITIES
HAVE A TRANSPORTATION.
OPTION THAT WORKS FOR THEM THEY
HAVE A WAY TO GET TO FRESNO TO
AXIS.
AND ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND ALSO
IT'S A IT'S A PROGRAM THAT'S
OPERATED BY RESIDENTS WITH --
ZERO EMISSIONS SO WE SEE THAT AS
A MODEL AND SOMETHING WE'RE
TRYING TO EXPAND -- WE'RE
WORKING WITH GREEN COMMUTER
AGAIN AND DEL HIGH AND ALSO
LOOKING AT KERN COUNTY AS
ANOTHER OPTION TO EXPAND THAT
PROGRAM.
BUT I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT THE STATE SHOULD LOOK HARD
AT TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THAT
WORK FOR COMMUNITIES AND ARE
TAILORED TO RURAL COMMUNITIES.
FINALLY I'M GONNA TURN A LITTLE
BIT TO AGRICULTURAL EMISSIONS --
ONE NEARLY UNIVERSAL FACT ABOUT
LIVING IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
AND THE EAST COAST COACHELLA
VALLEY IS PROXIMITY TO
AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS THESE
INCLUDE LARGE DAIRIES ALMOND
ORCHARDS GRAPEVINES FOOD
PROCESSING PLANTS.
AND DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES --
WITH RESPECT TO DERRY'S THERE'S
WELL BUT THERE IS AN IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE I'M GONNA TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE TIE BETWEEN
WATER QUALITY AND AIR QUALITY.
I WORK A LOT MORE ON THE WATER
QUALITY SIDE -- BUT THERE'S
DEFINITELY -- INTERSECTION THERE --
FOR DERRY'S MANURE MANAGEMENT
MANAGEMENT AT TERRY'S AND
INTERROGATE EMISSIONS FROM --
CALLOUS CONTRIBUTE FIVE POINT 4%
OF CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY FOURTEEN
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
INVENTORY AND FAR MORE WHEN
CALCULATED.
ON A TWENTY YEAR GLOBAL WARMING
POTENTIAL.
METHANE EMISSIONS FROM ENTERIC
FERMENTATION ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT
29% OF CALIFORNIA'S TOTAL
METHANE INVENTORY WELL MINORE
MANAGEMENT CONTRIBUTES ANOTHER
APPROXIMATELY 26%.
THIS IS A A BIG CHUNK OF THE
METHANE WITHIN THE STATE.
IN HOPE OF REDUCING EMISSIONS
THE STATE HAS INVESTED HUNDREDS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAXPAYER AND RATE PAYER
SUBSIDIES.
TOWARDS CONSTRUCTION OF DERRY
DIGESTERS A LOT OF WHICH ARE
LOCATED IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
WE THINK THERE'S NO EVIDENCE SO
FAR THAT THE STATE JESTERS ARE A
GOOD INVESTMENT GIVEN THAT WE
HAVE.
NO AIR QUALITY MONITORING TO
ESTABLISH EMISSION REDUCTIONS IF
ANY ASSOCIATED WITH THEIR DIGEST
ERRORS AND ADDITIONALLY THOUGH
DERRY DIGEST OUR PROGRAM
INCENTIVIZE IS AN INSURERS
CONTINUE DAIRY HERDS OF A SIZE
THAT ARE INCOMPATIBLE WITH GHG
REDUCTIONS.
AS WELL AS WATER QUALITY
PROTECTION.
THE STATE SHOULD BEGIN THE
REGULATOR IS TO ENSURE THAT THEY
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE METHANE
EMISSIONS AND SHOULD TAKE A MUCH
HARD TO LOOK AT MORE BENEFICIAL
PROGRAMS SELECT DRIVING OR
MANAGEMENT.
TURNING TO IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE
AND AND NITROUS OXIDE.
NITROUS OXIDE AS A PRIMARY
COMPONENT -- WITH AIR POLLUTION
AS WE KNOW A RECENT STUDY
CONCLUDES THAT 252401% OF THE
STATE'S NITROUS OXIDE.
IS RELATED TO IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE.
DECIDE NOT TO MISSIONS ARE
DIRECTLY TIES TO OVER
APPLICATION OF NITROGEN
FERTILIZER BY IRRIGATED
AGRICULTURE.
AND AGAIN THIS IS A CONNECTION
BETWEEN BOTH AIR QUALITY AND
WATER QUALITY SO OVER
APPLICATION OF FERTILIZER WHILE
BOTH -- DEGRADING OUR AIR
QUALITY IS HAVING A REALLY
NEGATIVE EFFECT ON WATER QUALITY
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AND
THE CENTRAL COAST'S SOME
SOMETIMES UPWARDS OF 40% OF
DOMESTIC WELLS.
ARE NOW CONTAMINATED WITH
NITRATE -- AND THIS IS AGAIN
DIRECTLY TIED OVER APPLICATION
OF FERTILIZER.
OUR RECOMMENDATION IS THAT THE
STATE BEGIN TO LOOK AT STRICT
LIMITS ON FERTILIZER
APPLICATIONS -- AND THAT THE
STATE MUST ALSO PUT IN PLACE
STRONG RESTRICTIONS ON PESTICIDE
APPLICATIONS FOR PROTECTION.
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
AND THEN FINALLY TO CONCLUDE
I'LL JUST SHARE A COUPLE OF
FINAL THOUGHTS REGARDING CLIMATE
CHANGE PLANNING AND INVESTMENTS
AND WRITE A REGULATIONS
IMPACTING.
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN AND THESE COACHELLA
VALLEY -- FOR ADAPTATION AND
RESILIENCE EFFORTS AND WROTE
COME IN A COMMUNITIES TO BE
EFFECTIVE WE NEED A FEW THINGS.
FIRST WE NEED A LOCAL PLANNING
THAT INCLUDES MEANINGFUL
OUTREACH AND ENGAGEMENT OF
EFFECTIVE COMMUNITY RESIDENT
RESIDENTS.
ON A COMMUNITY LEVEL AND THAT
WOULD INCLUDE SOLUTIONS
IDENTIFIED BY AND TAILORED TO
EACH COMMUNITY -- AND FINALLY WE
NEED TARGETED INVESTMENTS
FOCUSED ON RURAL COMMUNITIES AND
PARTICULAR DISADVANTAGED
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES AS AN
EXAMPLE OF THIS NEED.
AS A CONTINUED SHAME THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ARE
NOT YET ELIGIBLE FOR TCC --
CLIMATE OR TRANSFORMATIVE
COMMUNITY THIS PROGRAM
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS SB THREE
FIFTY ONE WOULD SEEK TO RIGHT
THIS WRONG AND WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO PASS IT THIS YEAR --
BY MAKING.
DISADVANTAGED UNINCORPORATED
COMMUNITIES ELIGIBLE FOR TCC
IMPLEMENTATION GRANTS RATHER
THAN JUST THE PLANNING GRANTS
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR FOR TODAY.
AND THEN FINALLY TO EFFECTIVELY
REDUCE METHANE NITROUS OXIDE AND
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY IN
COMMUNITIES IN CLOSE PROXIMITY.
TO AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS WE
NEED TO SEE EFFECTIVE SMART AND
STRONG REGULATIONS THAT REDUCE
FERTILIZER OVER APPLICATION AND
BEGIN TO REDUCE.
DAIRY HERD SIZES STELLAR TO
LEVELS WHERE PROTECTING AIR
QUALITY AND WATER QUALITY IS
FEASIBLE AND PRACTICABLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU ARE A I APPRECIATE THE
LAPPING MESSAGE THAT WE NEED TO
ENGAGE.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND A MORE
MEANINGFUL WAY AND ALLOW THEM TO
STEER OF BOTH THE IDENTIFICATION
OF PROBLEMS AND SOLUTIONS.
HOW THAT WORK FOR THEM AND THE
WORK WE STILL HAVE TO DO -- AS
THE STATE'S FIGURE THAT OUT --
IN ADDITION YOU YOU SPOKE ABOUT --
METHANE EMISSIONS AND SOME OF
THE LIMITATIONS WITH WITH
DAIRIES -- WITH THIRTY DAY
JUSTICE OUT THERE.
THEY NEED MENTION DRY MANY ARE
MANAGEMENT AND ARE THERE OTHER.
OF SOLUTIONS THAT YOU RECOMMEND
OTHER THAN THE DRIVE MANY ARE
MANAGEMENT THAT WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT YEAH SO THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION -- AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT JUST AS BACKGROUND. TO
REALIZE THAT THESE THEIR
DIGESTERS -- CAN ONLY CAPTURE
METHANE OVER DERRY LAGOON.
SO THAT IT THAT'S AN IMPORTANT
PIECE OF THE METHANE PUZZLE FOR
TERRY'S BUT IT'S NOT ALL OF IT --
SO THERE'S OTHER -- MINORE
MANAGEMENT THAT OCCURS AT
TERRY'S AND THESE STARED
ADJUSTERS DON'T HAVE ANY IMPACT
ON THAT MANY ARE MANAGEMENT
OUTSIDE THE LAGOONS.
AND IT ALSO HAS NO IMPACT ON
INTERROGATIONS -- FROM THE COUCH
THEMSELVES -- SO IN ADDITION TO
DRIVING OR MANAGEMENT WHICH THE
STATUS STARTED INVEST AND
PROBABLY NEEDS TO DO MORE.
BUT ALSO JUST REQUIREMENTS FOR
IMPROVED PRACTICES AROUND
DRIVING OR MANAGEMENT.
IN ADDITION OF THAT THOUGH WE
NEED TO TAKE A STRONG LOOK AT
DAIRY HERD SIZES WITHIN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY -- THOSE HERD
SIZES BASED ON A REPORT FROM THE
DAIRY INDUSTRY ITSELF IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
ARE BASICALLY INCOMPATIBLE RIGHT
NOW WITH WATER QUALITY
PROTECTION THAT THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY DID -- MONITORING
REPORT THAT CAME OUT EARLIER
THIS YEAR THE CONCLUSION OF THAT
REPORT IS THAT ALL DERRY'S
WITHIN THIS MONITORING PROGRAM
WHICH IS DISTRICT BE REPRESENTED.
OF THE INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY ALL OF THOSE
AREAS WERE POLLUTING GROUNDWATER.
AND THE SOLUTIONS TO THAT
PROBLEM RECOMMENDED BY THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY'S REPORT WERE ONE
FIGURE OUT WAYS TO EXPORT THIS
MAN OR IN A WAY THAT THEY CAN BE
SOLD.
FOR IRRIGATED AGRICULTURE AND
THEN AS A SECOND RECOMMENDATION
FROM THEIR INDUSTRIES REPORT
LOOK AT HEARD SIZES BECAUSE
WE'RE AND SO A SITUATION WHERE
IF YOU HAVE. FOR EXAMPLE SOME
BERRIES HAVE TEN THOUSAND HOUSE
OR MORE YOU HAVE THAT MANY COWS
THERE'S JUST NOT ANYTHING YOU
CAN DO WITH THE DAIRYMAN NORTH
THAT'S NOT GOING TO POLLUTE.
BOTH AIR QUALITY AND WATER
QUALITY SO A STRONG LOOK AT
THEIR HURTS US IS.
SO CAN -- WE TALK ABOUT THE
LAGOONS VERSUS THE HURT SIZE.
DRAMMEN OR WHAT HOW MUCH.
AND WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH DATA
YET ON THESE THIRTY DAY JUSTICE.
AWESOME LET'S SAY THAT MAYBE
THEY DO WORK FOR NOT.
LATE ENOUGH DATA TO SEE THAT'S
TRUE OR NOT -- BUT WHAT KIND OF
WHAT.
WHAT'S THE PERCENTAGE OF A
PORTION THAT'S NOT IN THE
LAGOONS HOW MUCH ABOUT THE NEVER
LEAVING BEHIND OF ONLY FOCUSING
ON TERRY THAT JESTERS.
I DON'T HAVE THE SPECIFIC NUMBER --
FOUR MANEUVER MANAGEMENT THOUGH
THE PORTION THAT'S LAGOONS THAN
THE PORTION THAT'S OUTSIDE OF
LAGOONS -- BUT IT'S 29% OF THE
TOTAL STATE WIDE -- METHANE
INVENTORY IS -- LAGOONS AND
OTHER MEN OR MANAGEMENT AND 26%
IS ENTERIC EMISSIONS OF I GOT
THAT RIGHT I CONFLICT.
I'M OKAY FOR OUR READY IN A TIME
SUCH MAYBE MY ONLY QUESTION
MICHAEL BUT THANK YOU I DO HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS FOR IN THE FUTURE
BUT SOME OF THIS METHANE STUFF
IN THERE THAT JUST OR SO.
FOLLOW UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
WE WILL NOW WRAP UP OUR
PRESENTATIONS AND ALLOW PUBLIC
COMMENT.
WELCOME TO COME UP I HAD A FOUR
PM GOAL WHICH I CLEARLY HAVE
EXCEEDED AND WILL EXCEED IT WILL
GIVE YOU THE TIME.
THAT YOU NEED 2% YOU'VE BEEN
PATIENTS WHOEVER WANTS TO SPEAK
AND SPEAK.
I WOULD JUST ASK YOU THAT HE
TRIED TO BE S. CONDENSE AS
POSSIBLE BUT I WON'T CUT ANYONE
OFF THANK YOU.
THE IS CONDENSED AS POSSIBLE
MICHAEL BOCA DOOR ON BEHALF OF
THE AG ENERGY CONSUMERS
ASSOCIATION WORK VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE DAIRY INDUSTRY AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A DISCUSSION
ABOUT DIED JESTERS WE'D LIKE TO
BE PART OF THAT DISCUSSION A LOT
OF THE INFORMATION YOU HEARD
TODAY.
MAY NOT BE ACCURATE WE HAVE VERY
GOOD NUMBERS ON HOW MUCH.
JERRY ARE REDUCING THEIR METHANE
EMISSIONS IT'S ROUGHLY FIFTY
FIFTY BETWEEN THE NEWER AND
ENTERIC THE PART THAT COMES
DIRECTLY FROM THE CAL.
THERE'S NO WAY OF REDUCING
METHANE DIRECTLY FROM THE COW
TODAY.
OF THE CERTAIN THINGS BEING
RESEARCHED AND REVIEWED BY FTA
AND OTHERS BUT THERE'S NO WAY TO
DO THAT WE'RE DOING A FANTASTIC
JOB WERE RUDE AND THE DERRY
DIGEST A PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA.
IS BY FAR THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PROGRAM THAT STATE IS
CURRENTLY INVESTING IN.
ITS REDUCING MORE TOTAL GHG THAN
ANY OTHER PROGRAM INCLUDING
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE FAR MORE
FUNDING.
AND SO SUGGESTIONS THAT WE
SHOULD QUIT FUNDING GEHRY DIED
JESTERS IS DIRECTLY CON SKIS ME
CONTRARY TO OUR GHG GOALS AND
METHANE REDUCTION GOALS IN
CALIFORNIA.
MORE IMPORTANTLY.
REDUCING HERD SIZES IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT GONNA REDUCE
METHANE.
SIMPLY GOING TO SHIFT NOTHING
PRODUCTION AND INCREASE IT BY
PUTTING IT IN OTHER STATES THAT
ARE NOT REDUCING METHANE TOTAL
DEMAND FOR GERRY IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
REDUCES HERD SIZES.
ARE HERDS ARE COMING DOWN HERE
BECAUSE WE'RE LOSING DAIRIES
WITH THESE FIFTY TO SIXTY
DERRY'S EVERY YEAR.
IN CALIFORNIA FOR THE FIRST TIME
OR HEARD TOTAL HURT CALIFORNIA'S
REDUCING.
SO WE WOULD BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE OF BEING PART OF
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION SO THAT
WE'RE GETTING ACCURATE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT THE DAIRY
INDUSTRY'S DOING TO REDUCE
METHANE IT'S ACTUALLY A
TREMENDOUSLY POSITIVE STORY.
WE WOULD WELCOME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE.
Q. ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
NOT.
FIFTEEN NON IDEA APPRECIATE
EVERYONE MAKING TIME FOR THIS --
UP DATA MISS MISS NICHOLS THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME I KNOW YOU'RE
BUSY BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
UPDATE AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
UPDATE.
IN THE FUTURE AND CONTINUED
CONVERSATIONS OUT THERE EVERYONE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED